Hallo, Chat.
Pog.
Oh, ich muss mein Headset kurz entknoten.
Wartet mal.
So, da bin ich.
Ups.
jetzt. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
es hört das Mikrofon irgendwie komisch an.
Aber ich habe irgendwie dreimal das Kabel aus
rumgewickelt.
So.
Fridge Physik. Dankeschön.
Pocket Subscription.
Huge.
So, erst mal was trinken hier.
Moin Leute.
Schön, dass ihr am
Zeit.
Also Erkältung ist schon wieder deutlich besser.
Ich denke mal, man hört es auch ein bisschen.
Dass ich mich nicht mehr ganz so krank anhöre, wie noch am Mittwoch?
Weiß gar nicht, weil wir gestreamt haben.
Donnerstag?
Irgendwann.
Letzte Woche.
Ein bisschen Nase laufen habe ich noch, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es eigentlich wieder okay.
Und glücklicherweise, ich hatte ja ziemlich so Geschmacks- und Geruchsverlust bei der Erkältung.
zum glück ist das auch wieder am start weil ihr wisst ja ich fresse ja gerne
war was ja aber dann nicht schmeckt ist schon ziemlich kacke der präsent schreibt
ich habe heute nacht gelernt hasse docker mit leib und seele ich bin zu
low acu dafür respekt an die das können was hast du denn getrieben also doch er
hat schon paar weird champion seiten gerade wenn man es für dinger benutzen
will wofür es nicht da ist also zum beispiel irgendwelche die automatischen
deployments mit wenig downtime und so was ja man kann das alles irgendwie
machen aber muss ich fragen so man eigentlich ist doch ursprünglich war das
ja dafür gedacht um dieses problem zu lösen
er läuft auf meinem pc und sonst nirgendwo also für für entwicklung
eigentlich unter anderem dass da leute jetzt irgendwie ihre produktiv services
auf docker laufen haben ja ja das geht ob es ursprünglich dafür gedacht war
wahrscheinlich eher nicht
lachs mit nudeln heute gibt's das war überlegen was ist noch da reis und
Garnelen.
Reis und Garnelen gibt's heute.
So sieht's aus.
Oh, gut.
Nee, Moment mal. Warum mach ich meine VM an?
Das ist falsch.
Nicht die VM einschalten, Max.
Linux Mini PC einschalten.
Omega Lul.
Wisst ihr mal.
Gewohnheit ist das hier wieder.
Macht der Gewohnheit.
Mini-PC.
Schalten wir den mal ein.
Eis und Kanälen.
Größer Nudel mit Lachs.
Nee, nee, nee.
Nudel mit Lachs besser.
Aber ich habe keinen Nudel mit Lachs.
Deswegen gibt es halt auch keinen Nudel mit Lachs.
Wo ich ja richtig Bock drauf hätte.
wäre, muss ich euch mal zeigen,
gleich, sobald
das hier gestartet ist,
wenn ich mein Passwort eingegeben habe,
Massive High IQ
Unbekanntes, kommt ihr nie drauf, Passwort.
Sollte das jetzt nicht gestartet sein?
Ah ja, okay.
Exzellent.
So.
Es gibt bei uns hier
einen Laden, da hätte ich mega Bock
heute drauf. Vielleicht mache ich das nachher
auch. Mal gucken.
Gibt bei uns ein
Laden, der nennt sich so
Tuk Tuk. Wie diese
komischen Fahrradautos oder was das
ist aus Indien.
Und das Ding, also
bei dem, das ist so ein Asia
Laden, der aber besser ist
als der normale 0815 Asia Imbiss.
Schmeckt mega nice.
Und was ich hier gerne hole ist...
Warte mal, ich muss niesen, Sekunde.
Geschnetzeltes... Wo ist es denn?
Züricher Geschnetzeltes à la Tuk Tuk.
Das esse ich mega... Block.
Das esse ich mega gern.
Und da habe ich heute eigentlich richtig Bock drauf.
Mal was zu bestellen.
Das einzige Ding ist, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob die heute aufhaben.
Ab 16 Uhr. Öffnen um 16 Uhr.
Na, das ist natürlich Kacke. Da kann ich mir für Mittag erst
nichts bestellen. Aber wer Hanau und
Umgebung ist, den Laden kann ich echt als Lieferservice
empfehlen. Schmeckt mega nice.
So.
Chaterino starten.
Habe versucht mit AI zwei
Docker-Files und eine Compose-Yaml zusammenzustellen,
um fünf Container ein Dutzend Tasks laufen
zu lassen.
Das ist eine Übungssache. Echt. Also,
ich kriege aus dem Kopf
kriege ich auch keine docker compose falls hin ich muss man dann immer ein paar examples angucken
was ich mittlerweile aus dem kopf zumindest mit visual studio plugin ganz gut hinkriege
sind kubernetes services und kubernetes deployment definitionen was mache ich einfach öfters als
compose files erzählt einmal auch viel mist da sind immer so kleine subtile sachen drin die
die sich dazu halluziniert.
Und dann denkst du, warum funzt das nicht?
Warum funzt das nicht?
Wisst ihr, was ich sehr merkwürdig finde?
In letzter Zeit brüsten sich ganz viele CEOs und CTOs
und hast du nicht gesehen?
Chefentwickler und sonst was.
Damit, letztens hat auch Spotify, glaube ich,
wieder irgendwo geschrieben.
Unsere Entwickler haben ein halbes Jahr
schon keine zeile code mehr von hand geschrieben wird alles von erledigt ich weiß gar nicht ob das
so eine gute idee ist sich damit zu brüsten ich glaube der der hype dass man das gut findet ist
schon ziemlich abgelaufen mittlerweile ja also die meisten leute sagen er gehe mal weg ich habe
keinen bock nur noch weib code zu verwenden ich meine das beste beste beispiel dafür wollte ich
sagen das beste beispiel dafür ist ja immer noch microsoft die windows immer schlimmer machen und
ich kann es ja bei der gelegenheit das war nämlich keine ahnung wusste ich gar nicht dass es das gab
das beste beispiel ist ja immer noch microsoft was die mit was was die mit windows einstellen
Und ich bin der Meinung, die Einzigen, die es schaffen können, dass das Jahr des Linux-Desktops wird, ist Microsoft selbst.
Microsoft selbst.
Und ich meine, ey, ohne Scheiß, Microsoft ist hart daran am Arbeiten, dass das Jahr des Linux-Desktops wird, gell?
Also so beschissen, wie die letzten Windows-Updates waren und wie vorbei.
Ich frage mich immer nur so, wie krass man vorbei entwickeln kann an dem, was die Leute wollen.
Aber Microsoft schafft es ja auf ganzer Linie, immer wieder.
Habt ihr auch gelesen, Windows 12, ups, äh, the fuck, Windows 12 AI only, so nach dem Motto, äh, Windows 12 soll irgendwie so ein reines AI-Betriebssystem werden, ne, ob das jetzt, Windows 12 irgendwie kommt oder so, ja, keine Ahnung, das ist N-Shittification überall, genau.
und wo wir gerade beim Thema Entritification sind, ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen, Chat, und die, die es wissen, die Stream dabei waren, wo ich es erzähle, aber die es vielleicht auf Newsseiten gelesen haben, seid mal ruhig jetzt, mich würde es interessieren für die Leute, die es noch nicht wissen, was glaubt ihr denn, in welcher Technologie oder sagen wir mal in welcher Programmiersprache, Schrägstrich Randheim, Schrägstrich Technologie,
als mir egal was man als genau nennt das wird auch startmenü programmiert ist also so aus dem bauch
raus ja würde man ja wahrscheinlich sagen ja vielleicht dort netzisch ab oder vielleicht
low level c++ windows api zeug oder sowas ja würde würde man würde man eigentlich davon ausgehen ja
ja es ist scharf das hätten wir würde ich ehrlich gesagt ursprünglich auch gedacht hätte gedacht
ursprünglich, dass das
eine, also, bevor ich es wusste, hätte ich
gedacht, das ist eine C-Sharp
UWP-App oder irgendwie sowas,
was sonst kein Sau verwendet,
aber es ist korrekt,
es ist JavaScript.
Es ist JavaScript.
Es ist React, ich weiß
nicht, ob es React oder React
Native ist, können wir eigentlich auch
gerade mal suchen.
Windows 11 Start
Menu React
It uses Microsoft's React Native for Windows
Also es ist kein
Okay, okay, guck mal
Es ist kein WebView, es ist React Native
React Native heißt
Es verwendet tatsächlich Steuerelemente
Aus dem jeweiligen OS oder von irgendeinem OS
Das ist quasi
Boah, was, Alter
Das ist ja, okay, es sind
Es ist unter der Haube vielleicht sogar
WPF?
Ach du Scheiße.
Okay, Moment. Wie darf ich mir das jetzt vorstellen?
Es ist JavaScript
React Native, was
wiederum irgendwelche
WinUI-Sachen
oder so benutzt.
Alter Fall, das ist so um...
Du hast gedacht, das wäre ein Witz, ne?
Das ist richtig.
Du hast recht gehabt, das ist in JavaScript programmiert.
Man glaubt das gar nicht so richtig, ne?
Aber es ist so.
Moin, Bloodcake.
Das ist so.
Es ist tatsächlich in...
Das heißt, die haben das irgendwann in React neu gemacht.
Richtig.
Das ist...
Also es gibt ja...
Ich hab letztens auf Reddit so was cooles gesehen.
Wartet mal.
Guck mal, ob ich das finde.
Windows Taskbar Evolution.
reddit letzten post gesehen genau hier und ihr seht schon dass ich alleine in
windows 10 und windows und windows 11 das windows 8 hier noch gerne aussehen
wenn das das so oft geändert hat okay man erkennt jetzt jetzt hat sich eine
optisch gar nicht so viel geändert aber die haben bestimmt fünf mal oder so die
technologie gehen oder wenn man zurückgehen sein windows 8 hat sich da
hat sich keine ahnung zehn mal oder so die technologie geändert die unter der
startleiste darunter ist also ich okay das kann sein dass ich jetzt müsst
erzählen ob es noch gibt und ich glaube ich glaube selbst gibt es noch weil es
anwendungen gibt die auf wp aufsetzen und dementsprechend kann nicht weg aber
mittlerweile ist das alles wenn ui das gp ging wohl irgendwie in video auf aber
ganz ehrlich microsoft windows und ui frameworks ist absoluter fiebertraum wie
die suche programmiert haben ich würde mal behaupten die haben die suche gar
nicht programmiert weil die suche funktioniert nicht ist der calculator
nach open source ich glaube schon github kalk windows glaube das ist ja der
windows calculator der ist der ist anscheinend noch open source was ja geil
für das ding ein 30.000 sterne hat
moment was ist denn das
Ist das irgendeine Mischung aus C++ und WinUI oder was?
Was ist das hier für eine wilde Mischung?
Ich muss sagen, das ist...
Moment, das ist .NET C Sharp.
Das ist CLA C Sharp.
Oh, nee.
Es gibt wirklich Leute, die das benutzen?
angeblich angeblich passieren große teile von frost bei auch darauf also nicht nicht
nicht von der frost bei nicht von der frost bei den selbst sondern von den frost bei entwickler
tools basiert angeblich ein großteil auf dort netz hier plus plus ich habe das daran erkannt
hier das da das ist das ist so eine so eine syntax oder so eine so eine typ
zugefügt in den clr c++ alter diesen kram benutzt jemand monka w aller grausam
Das sind die, das sind die, Microsoft, Microsoft ist noch schlimmer.
Microsoft denkt sich laufend neue Frameworks und sowas aus,
stellt sie aber dann auch zeitgleich irgendwie wieder ein,
aber du hast trotzdem parallel und oftmals benutzen sie ihren eigenen Scheiß nicht.
Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Also Windows ist ganz wild.
Und ich bin auch der Meinung, Microsoft hat einen entscheidenden Anteil mit daran geleistet, mit ihrer komplett wirren und unnachvollziehbaren Windows-UI-Framework, wie nennt man das heutzutage, Neudeutsch oder Neubusiness-Speak, so schön, Story, mit ihrer UI-Story, haben sie das so verkackt.
und ich bin der Meinung, die haben da einen entscheidenden Beitrag zu geleistet,
dass so Sachen wie Elektron und sowas auf dem Desktop überhaupt so groß geworden sind, wie sie jetzt sind.
Nicht alleine, ja.
Mein Elektron hat natürlich schon riesen Vorteile in der heutigen Zeit,
wo es erstmal Web-Anwendungen gibt und dann vielleicht nur eine Desktop-Anwendung
und man im Endeffekt die Web-Anwendung nimmt mit ein paar Anpassungen,
die wahrscheinlich auch auf allen Plattformen drauf sind, aber mit einem großes If drumherum.
Und das sind quasi ein eigenes Browser-Fenster für den Desktop-Pakt.
Das kann ich sogar nachvollziehen, warum die das gemacht haben.
Digga, und ich muss kurz Nase putzen.
Das kann ich sogar nachvollziehen.
Die wollten ein möglichst einfach...
Also sie wollten mehrere Sachen.
Wenn ich das richtig, ich habe mir damals das Video angeguckt von Anders Heilsberg,
das ist ja der TypeScript und C-Sharp Erfinder.
Und wenn der TypeScript und C-Sharp Erfinder sagt, sie wollen das nicht in C-Sharp machen,
dann hat das, finde ich, schon ein gewisses Gewicht, dass der sich da Gedanken drüber gemacht hat.
Also meines Wissens ist das so, dass sie wollten erstens relativ einfach Sachen portieren können,
von TypeScript zu einer anderen Programmiersprache, in dem Fall Go.
und die Ähnlichkeit zwischen TypeScript und Go war größer,
dass die Portierung einfacher macht.
Das ist das Erste.
Das Zweite ist,
dass sie es möglichst einfach portierbar haben wollen,
oder nee, muss ich anders sagen,
möglichst einfach Cross-Plattform haben wollen
und es gibt für solche Tools nichts Besseres als Go,
um Sachen Cross-Plattform zu machen.
Ich glaube, Go ist mit Abstand die einfachste Programmiersprache,
die es gibt.
Oder was ist Programmiersprache?
Runtime-Technologie, die es gibt, um Cross-Plattform, Cross-Architektur, Self-Contained Anwendungen zu erstellen.
Da gibt es eigentlich nichts besseres wie Go.
Guck dir mal, in welcher anderen Programmiersprache, sagt mir eine Programmiersprache oder so eine Runtime-Technologie,
wo es so ähnlich ist, wo es so einfach ist wie in Go, eine Anwendung unter Linux auf einem Raspberry Pi zu entwickeln
und sie auf einem Windows x86 laufen zu lassen.
Also quasi auf einem Raspberry Pi auf Armarchitektur eine Anwendung bauen
und dann für alle Plattformen zu kompilieren.
Python hast du schon das Problem, dass du Python schon keine gescheite Self-Contained-Anwendung auf die Reihe kriegst.
Ohne große Aktionen.
aktion da hat er schon mal auf dabei selbst konnte in anwendungen in peinz
super peinz champ läuft jetzt warum fängt jetzt an die nase zu laufen
also das gibt es nichts fällt mir nichts ein
C Sharp ist mittlerweile so ein bisschen auf dem Weg dahin mit ihrer IoT-Geschichte, aber das funktioniert auch noch nicht so gut.
Ja, kannst du, kannst du, aber es ist noch bei weitem nicht so schön, wie das in Go ist.
Also du kannst das, aber C Sharp fängt ja schon an, dass einige Libraries nicht IoT-kompatibel sind,
dass wenn du IoT verwendest, du immer noch eine Abhängigkeit zur Plattform LibC hast, je nachdem.
ähm
AOT Cross Compilen
ist auch nicht so
einfach von Linux zu Windows
also im Vergleich zu
Go
ist das immer noch komplizierter, aber sie sind
auf jeden Fall auf dem Weg dahin, ne und die
wollten einfach eine Programmiersprache, wo es
einfach, wo einfach
Rust geht in der Tat ganz
gut, wobei auch das Cross Compiling Rust nicht so
schön ist, ähm
sie haben übrigens auch, Rust
hat
zumindest wenn man unter Linux auf der gleichen
Hardware-Architektur bleibt,
also von Linux x86 auf andere Linux x86,
ist Rust ziemlich gut.
Wenn man das mit Musel als
Target kompiliert,
dann ist Rust ziemlich gut.
Dann funzt das auch.
Haben wir im Stream schon ausprobiert.
Sie haben aber auch begründet,
warum sie TypeScript nicht in Rust
rewritten haben oder portiert haben.
Da muss ich mich an der Stelle tatsächlich nochmal selbst loben,
weil ich habe einen der Hauptgründe schon genannt damals,
bevor wir das Video von Anders Heilsberg geguckt haben.
Und zwar, ich dachte mir es nämlich schon,
letztendlich geht es ja hier darum, im größeren Stil einen Compiler zu implementieren.
Und Rust ist richtig abartig, um Compiler zu implementieren,
weil compiler oder generell ist so so so syntax trees und so was haben sehr
viele self reference in self referenzierenden daten strukturen und
das ist in rust paint champ und das war eines der gründe nicht mehr gleich von
anfang an gedacht hat warum sie nicht was genommen haben und das hat er dann
aber auch gesagt in seinem video das ist halt eine sehr grüne warum nicht was
und ich meine, ihr könnt von ausgehen, bei Anders Heilsberg liegt es nicht daran, dass er großer Fanboy von Go ist
und das unbedingt in Go machen wollte.
Erstens ist Go von Google, nicht von Microsoft.
Zweitens ist er TypeScript und die Sharp-Erfinder.
Also wenn der sagt, er macht das in Go, da kannst du von ausgehen, das hat schon handfeste Vorteile für die,
dass sie das in Go machen.
Ich glaube,
dass die
Dinger bei Microsoft, was, also
man muss ja sagen, GitHub hat ja auch ein bisschen abgebaut,
finde ich, so das letzte Jahr über.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck,
dass wenn Microsoft Entwicklertools
baut, Entwicklersachen,
dass sie da ein bisschen mehr freie Hand
haben, wobei da auch
ziemlich AI-Entzündification am Laufen
ist, aber es gab
ja schon zwischenzeitlich mal
so
Testballons, nenne ich es jetzt mal,
wo sie versucht haben,
bestimmte Sachen rauszuschmeißen
aus Visual Studio Code oder
dass irgendwelche, sie hatten mal
versucht einzubauen, dass
in .NET, in der .NET CLI manche
Sachen nicht mehr gingen, außer
mit Lizenz und sowas, aber das wurde dann
immer relativ schnell wieder eingefangen.
doch mein interesse an ist da ich sehe aber nicht als das lösen für alle probleme wir benutzen
eigentlich ist so gut wie jeden stream in irgendeiner form sei es dass wir auch ein
code verwenden oder dass wir bei irgendwelchen er ist was nachgucken oder sonst was im programmier
stream sogar noch mehr aber ich sehe das nicht als heilsbringer für alles ja
also auch keiner mit bisschen iq sieht das so außer leute die es verkaufen
wollen bei microsoft ist es ja mittlerweile so schlimm dass der chef
ja da angeblich eine rundmail geschrieben hat dass wer keinen bock auf
auf AI hat, soll sich gleich verpissen,
so nach dem Motto. Das ist auch schon hart, oder?
Ach ja, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Ich habe letztens wieder gesehen, hier Firefox.
Da gab es letztens eine Meldung
von Firefox,
die gesagt haben,
ähm,
Das meine ich nicht
Ich habe letztens
In News von Mozilla gelesen
Dass die erstaunt
Waren darüber
Das meine ich gar nicht hier
Dass die erstaunt waren darüber
Dass die Leute es nicht total abfeiern
Dass Firefox ein AI Browser
Werden soll
Und da haben die letztens in News gepostet
Und haben gesagt
Oh, wir haben euch erhört
Es gab ein großes
Es gab ganz viel tolles Feedback
Unserer Benutzer
Und es gab einen großen Pushback
Gegen AI
Und sie werden darauf achten
Da frage ich mich
Wie vorbei an dem entwickeln
Was die Leute wollen
In welche anderen Sphären
Musste da als CEO schweben
Dass du das nicht mitkriegst
Wobei mich es oftmals auch gar nicht so richtig wundert, weil, wenn, überlegt euch mal, ihr seid in so einem Unternehmen, ja, und euer Chef sagt, ey, Leute, wer keinen Bock auf AI hat, soll sich verpissen.
Jetzt mal übertrieben gesagt, ja
Dann hat er natürlich selbstverständlich
Nur noch Leute um sich
Die dieses Thema extrem abfeiern
Und selbst wenn sie es persönlich nicht so abfeiern wie der CEO
Sie werden auf jeden Fall, um sich einzuschleimen, das abfeiern
Ja, also wenn, guck mal
Stellt euch vor, ihr seid irgendwie aus
In irgendeinem Unternehmen da Karriere zu machen
Und euer Chef sagt euch
AI, beste, wir müssen alles in AI machen
So, da denkt ihr euch natürlich
wenn ihr jetzt Karriere machen wollt, ja erzählt
dem doch laufend irgendwas von tollen
AI-Entwicklungen und was ihr nicht
vorhabt, weil ihr denkt, das ist förderlich für eure
Karriere und dementsprechend
der will es nicht anders
und er hört es auch nicht anders und
dementsprechend
kann es durchaus sein,
dass die dem sogar ganz andere Sachen erzählen
als der Realität entspricht.
Zum Beispiel, stellt euch vor, ihr seid
in so einem Unternehmen drin,
euer Chef sagt, AI, beste, wir wollen nur noch
AI und ihr seid in irgendeiner Marketingabteilung,
macht ein bisschen Marktforschung
und stellt fest, die Leute
wollen eigentlich gar kein AI.
Wollt ihr wirklich das Risiko eingehen,
zu eurem Chef zu gehen und euch unbeliebt zu machen?
Also wenn ihr, ne?
Wenn ihr auf Karriere aushalten in dem Unternehmen
und sagen, ey Leute,
Chef, das ist glaube ich keine so gute Idee, was du
da erzählt hast. Die Leute wollen eigentlich gar
keine KI. Ne.
Die gehen da zu ihrem Chef und sagen, Leute,
wir haben eine Umfrage gemacht und 30%
unserer leute würden lieber heute als morgen nur noch im browser haben da sagt
der chef ist geil alter genau das was ich mir gedacht habe bin ich hier
visionär kann ich mich beim nächsten golf spielen mit den anderen leuten kann
ich mich darüber unterhalten wie krasser visionär ich bin und dann gibt es ganz
viele obwohl das eigentlich die nutzer gar nicht haben wollen
da macht erst mal linkedin post
ja so mein max was hältst du vom allgemeinen konsens dass man jetzt sagt die kri agenten
er das code übernehmen oder die informatiker immer dass man jetzt sagt die kri agenten er
das programmieren also programmieren und informatik das managen der hier hat ios
nur mit whatsapp sprach der hier hat eine ios app nur mit whatsapp sprach
ja das sind so nette versuchs dinger und da gibt es ja immer wieder irgendwelche
projekte oder irgendwelche ich meine man darf sich überlegen wie viel vibe code
mittlerweile ist von der ganzen software die auch auf github ist und so was ich
sage sondern letztens gab es einen größeren gab es dann etwas größeren
Shitstorm bei Booklore.
Hat das jemand mitgekriegt?
Booklore, Booklore, Shitstorm.
So ein bisschen. Da haben Leute
festgestellt, der Entwickler
programmiert gar nicht mehr selbst.
Der mergt gefühlt jeden Tag irgendwelche
20.000 Zeilen
ähm
Pull-Requests und sowas.
Ja gut, hier hat sich nicht so viel getan.
Und das irgendwie
gab es riesen Shitstorm, alles AI und
bla und sonst was. Naja.
Guck mal hier. Alter!
Was für Riesen... Das ist ja
Massive PR, Alter.
Ist auch wurscht. Zumindest gab's da ein bisschen
Shitstorm deswegen, dass das alles
nur noch Vibe-Coded,
Vibe-Coded ist. Also da ist viel, viel Vibe-Coded.
Ich persönlich glaube nicht,
dass Entwickler großartig ihre Jobs verlieren werden
durch Vibe-Code.
Ich gehe eher davon aus, dass in Zukunft
noch ganz viel
Vibe-Codeder Bullshit, der da so
unter der Haube schlummert, noch nicht aufgefallen ist,
wieder von Leuten von Hand raus operiert werden muss.
Ich glaube, es ist ein feiner Grad, den man da bei KI-Entwicklung gehen muss,
zwischen hilfreicher Unterstützung und Blindsachen in irgendeinen Agent reinschmeißen,
den machen lassen und vordergründig denken, es funktioniert,
nur um dann irgendwie einem halben jahr festzustellen also geil was ja doch nicht
also man kann das als unterstützung verwenden das machen wir gefühlt auch in jedem stream
auch in jedem programmier stream so nach dem motto er könnte man das noch irgendwie schöner
machen oder hast du eine idee wie man das in go macht so sieht sind sie scharf aus oder wie würde
man das und das so machen und sich da inspiration holen das machen wir auch total oft aber ein
komplettes entwickeln von ki und man braucht keine programmierer mehr das glaube ich nicht und ich
behaupte jetzt einfach auch mal dieses große programmierer werden abend werden arbeitslos
durch KI
ist noch nirgendwo
groß passiert
und wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht passieren.
Du wirst auch weiterhin selbst programmieren.
Aber ja,
ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass
es sich ein bisschen verschiebt
und durchaus in Zukunft
noch mehr Code von AI
erstellt wird.
Und sich jemand um die passenden Prompts und Reviews kümmern muss.
Ja, das wird sich schon ein bisschen verschieben.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir es in nächster Zeit erleben werden.
Wobei, doch, ich glaube, dass wir es in nächster Zeit erleben werden, dass viele Unternehmen einen Großteil ihres Codes in KI erstellen.
Aber ich glaube auch, dass wir es erleben werden, dass das nicht auf lange Sicht gut gehen wird.
Stellenanzeige für Entwickler sind am steigen.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass wir auch in 1-2 Jahren sehen,
dass dieser ganze Vibe-gecodete Shit, den da manche erstellt haben,
nicht mal wartbar ist.
Es kann mir keiner erzählen, dass diese ganzen Leute,
die einen 40-Stunden-Job haben und noch nebenbei 20 Projekte,
Side-Hustlen und
Vibe-Coden,
dass die ihre Software
verstehen
beziehungsweise
ordentlich weiterentwickeln können
auf lange Sicht. Also das
sehe ich einfach nicht.
Mein Arsch läuft.
Nicht bewahrbar ist zum Beispiel sowas, also ich mal mir da jetzt was aus, ja, wo ich mir halt vorstellen kann, wo es richtig schwierig wird ist, wenn es halt irgendwelche Bugs gibt.
Zum Beispiel, Webseite geht manchmal, refresht sich manchmal nicht automatisch, sondern muss mit F5 refreshed werden. Woran liegt das?
Finde das mal raus in einem vibegecodeten Dschungel, den noch nie ein Mensch vorher gesehen hat.
Das ist denen so lange egal, wie alles läuft.
Dann ist das denen auch nicht mehr egal.
Also spätestens, wenn sich Leute, die die Software gekauft haben,
oder halt User, die die Software benutzen und da mit Kohle reinspringen,
abhauen, weil die Qualität so schlecht ist,
wird das der
Management-Ebene nicht egal sein.
Die
Erkenntnis muss aber wahrscheinlich noch
bei allen ankommen.
Also, dass
Programmierer arbeitslos werden,
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch noch nirgendwo passiert,
dass wirklich Entwickler wegen
KI, dass Leute gesagt haben,
Also im großen Stil, ja. Meine Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel. Das ist nicht jetzt irgendwo mal bei irgendeinem Unternehmen irgendwie ein paar Leute rausgeschmissen wurden. Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Wobei ich ja eher denke, dass bevor Programmierer ersetzt werden oder bevor Admins und DevOps-Leute und Engineer-Leute ersetzt werden, werden ganz viele Bullshit-Jobs durch AI ersetzt.
Also, da könnte ich mir das vorstellen, ja
Die Leute, die am Tag 5 Excel-Tabellen erstellen müssen
Oder irgendwelche komischen PDF-Reports erstellen müssen
Es gab letztens auch eine Thread, habe ich letztens gelesen
Dass angeblich KI bessere Entscheidungen trifft als die meisten Manager
Ich weiß nicht auf welcher Basis sie das angeblich rausgefunden haben, gab es aber letztens einen größeren News-Post drüber.
Da bin ich mir aber gar nicht so sicher, ob das wirklich an KI aktuell liegt.
Vielleicht mit, ja.
Generell ist ja der Jobmarkt ziemlich im Arsch da.
Nee, nee
Ich war krank, jetzt ist es eine Woche
Hab ich nicht viel gemacht
Bei uns ist es übrigens gar nicht so
Wir haben jetzt wieder drei neue Junior-Stellen
Ähm, Junior Storage Admin
Junior
Boah, keine Ahnung, irgendwas aus dem DevOps-Bereich
Keine Ahnung, wie das genau heißt
Und ein Entwickler
habe ich letztens erst gesehen also es ist also bei uns werden also wenn man so in der in der
summe in der summe sieht wenn aktuell mehr juniors gesucht ein team ist sich als seniors
bei senior suchen sie glaube ich gerade nur einen für ich glaube netzwerk wenn ich das richtig im
Kopf habe.
Aber den suchen sie irgendwie schon seit Jahren und finden
keinen. Also Leute, ne?
Netzwerke am Start hier.
Netzwerke zu finden
ist anscheinend wirklich schwer.
Ich bin auch nicht ganz
fit.
Ja, ja, ja. Das
sehe ich auch so.
Ja.
im künstlerischen Bereich,
da sehe ich große Probleme.
So
Illustrator, Fotos,
teilweise auch Webdesign und sowas.
Da sehe ich tatsächlich
echt Einschnitte.
Aber ich finde, da sieht man halt auch
die Qualität. Also vielen
ist die Qualität gefühlt ja auch egal.
Bei mir, hier,
ich hoffe, man sieht es
auf Google Maps.
Hier gibt es ein Aldi in der Nähe.
Hanau.
So, da muss ich ja was
muss ich euch was zeigen.
Hanau.
Ich hoffe man sieht das.
So, hier geht die Straße
vorbei. Ich hoffe es gibt Street View
und das ist ein neues Street View.
So, und hier
Hier gibt es eine Werbung
von einem Dönerladen.
Oder hier?
Ah, ne!
Die gibt's doch nicht.
Hier hängt eine Werbung
von einem Dönerladen.
Die ist so hart
AI generiert.
Weibdönert.
Hier irgendwo hängt die mittlerweile.
Das Foto ist... Ah, das Foto von 2022.
Okay.
Also die ist sowas von heftig
Weibdönert.
Aber das juckt den halt nicht.
Der hat da seinen AI generierten
Dönerspieß und hat
im Endeffekt einen Schriftzug drüber gemacht.
Und dann ist gut.
Die interessiert das nicht, ob das schlechte
Qualität ist oder sowas. Aus denen ihre Augen
Ist das gut? Und ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Werbeagenturen mittlerweile AI-Slob raushauen, weil es billig ist.
Ich habe ja immer noch ein CT-Abo.
Also hier.
Beise.
Habe ich seit...
Ne, nicht Computertomographie.
ein CT-Abo schon, wie gesagt,
seit zig
Jahrzehnten eigentlich schon.
Ich hab bestimmt schon, boah, keine Ahnung,
über 20 Jahre hab ich ein CT-Abo.
Und, guck mal hier.
Die haben total viele Bilder
mittlerweile drin. Die sind so offensichtlich
KI. Da frag ich mich,
ey,
sind da jetzt alle Illustratoren
und Grafiker arbeitslos geworden
mittlerweile?
Also,
sie haben total viel
gefühlt hat jeder zweite ct artikel mittlerweile ja guckt euch das hier an
jeder gefühl jeder zweite ct artikel ist generiert die bilder
die kommentarsektion ist wild ja
Du kannst das bestätigen als Netzwerk-Admin.
Ja, es ist echt schwierig, Netzwerkleute zu finden, so wie es aussieht.
Call-Center durch KI.
Ganz ehrlich, bei vielen Call-Centern gehe ich sogar von aus, das funktioniert besser mit KI.
Wir hatten auf der alten Arbeit
Hatten wir
Einen Dienstleister
Der hatte sein Callcenter irgendwo in Tschechien
Oder so
Du konntest da auf Deutsch
Und Englisch anrufen
Es war vollkommen egal, die haben dich nicht verstanden
Hast du angerufen
Äh, hier, wir haben hier eine Meldung bekommen
Äh, Switch ist kaputt
Äh, was ist, was ist denn kaputt
Eine Switch, was ist eine Switch
Was, was
Ist hier eintragen
Die waren ganz schlimm, die konntest du komplett vergessen
Ganz ehrlich, da wäre es wahrscheinlich mit KI besser funktioniert
Da hätte es wahrscheinlich mit KI besser funktioniert
Du konntest es nicht selber machen, weil die Netzwerkhardware eben von denen administriert wurde
und du musst, also, wir hatten
ein Netzwerkkram,
ein Netzwerkkram-Dienstleister
und der hatte eine 24-7-Rufbereitschaft
und
Leute vor Ort,
aber damit
du das alles triggern konntest,
du durftest die oder konntest die nicht direkt anrufen,
du musstest das immer mit dieser chesischen Hotline machen.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, Nass haben wir noch nicht alles eingerichtet.
Konnt die Woche nicht.
Ich wollte auf irgendwas hier noch was sagen, aber ich finde es nicht mehr.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Naja, wurscht.
Tunas wird jetzt Clouster, wird es?
Was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass das Build-System oder die Build-Configs und Sachen nicht mehr Open Source sind.
Ja, es gab hier auf Reddit, wo wir gerade noch bei Booklore sind,
gab es einen riesen...
Riesen-Shitstorm.
Na, Riesen-Shitstorm.
Shitstorm über Booklore.
Das ist keine gute Idee, das zu verwenden.
Und...
Irgendwie hatte der Entwickler von Booklore dann den übelsten Meltdown in Discord und hat alles umgeschrieben und gelöscht, was ihm nicht gepasst hat und hat dann irgendwann noch einen Antwortspost verfasst, wo er eigentlich auf nichts eingeht in den Kommentaren, was an Kritik ist, außer sich darüber aufregt, dass die Leute keine Ahnung von Vibe-Coding haben und sowas.
Also das ist auch wieder so ein Beispiel, wie man solche Sachen so maximal unbefriedigend handhaben kann.
Er ist in Crash-Out gegangen, würde der Zoomer sagen.
Sagt er das so? Okay.
So, dann machen wir mal OS-Updates, würde ich sagen.
Wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich hier drauf gekommen?
Achso, genau, weil ich euch fragen wollte
Mit was die Windows-Hassleiste
Programmiert ist ja
Ist Booklore gevibecoded? Angeblich
War es so, Booklore ist
Nicht als vibecoded Projekt gestartet
Aber ist mittlerweile zum größten
Teil vibecoded
Da gibt es PRs, die einfach
Mal pro Tag irgendwie
20.000 Codezeilen enthalten
Wo der Entwickler
die
Cloud Opus 4.6
Commit Messages quasi weg macht,
dass es nicht aussieht wie
Vibe-Coded
und dass sie wohl auch ziemliche Qualitätsprobleme
aktuell haben.
Und der Entwickler auf Discord
alles löscht, was in diese Richtung geht.
So, das war so die kurze Zusammenfassung des
Book-Claude-Dramas, was es
so in den letzten paar Tagen gegeben hat.
Ich benutze Book-Claude nicht, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt noch nicht,
genau was es ist ich glaube es ist eine hosting platz plattform wenn man selbst
den content besitzt also die lux distribution in dem fall natürlich was
sonst also wenn man selbst bücher content besitzt dass man das quasi
zugreifbar macht aus überall aus dem netzwerk und sowas kalibre
wird ki probleme probleme erschaffen die man dann wieder lösen muss er klar
Passiert das schon täglich?
Aha.
Mittlerweile,
mittlerweile muss man aber auch mal sagen,
ist das ja fast schon ein bisschen Hexenverfolgungs
mäßig auf GitHub, ne?
Mittlerweile wird ja bei allem Vibecode
gewittert.
Ob es Vibecode ist oder nicht.
Das hier beschreibt die Stimmung ganz gut
Okay, was schreibt der Wolfgang denn?
Sorry for Doom Posting
Komm, wir
Wo wir gerade beim Thema AI sind.
Komm.
Übersetzen.
Wir können auch DeepL verwenden.
Entschuldigung für den Duma-Post.
Aber ich glaube,
AI-Slob hat die letzten winzigen Reste
an Leidenschaft zerstört,
die ich noch für die Homelapse-Szene hatte,
sagt er.
Jeder zweite Post auf dem Subreddit
self-hostet beginnt inzwischen mit
Ich habe gebaut was im grunde übersetzt heißt cloud code hat es gebaut
Das stimmt ja dass mir auch schon aufgefallen ich habe sogar letztens konnte die büte zu einem
Will nicht sagen slob
Projekt github
Da gab es nämlich
Format library wo jemand peyton rich zu
zu Rust umgevibecoded hat.
Man muss sich nur mal das Logo angucken.
Man sieht sofort, dass das gevibecoded ist.
Und ich habe ein Issue aufgemacht hier.
Guck, ob es nicht möglich ist,
dass man hier den Spinner ändern kann.
Also, okay, Leute,
Contributed ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel des Guten, ja?
Ich habe ein Issue aufgemacht
Er hat danach einen Vibe-Coded Change-Request eingereicht mit 120 Spinnern.
Aber immerhin, das Projekt funzt ganz gut.
Trotz Vibe-Code.
Also, lass mal kurz weiterlesen.
50% dieser selbstgebauten Projekte sind für den persönlichen Gebrauch oder sehr spezielle Nischenfälle.
Aber die andere Hälfte hat tatsächlich die Dreistkeit nach mitwirkenden Spenden.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Ja, das wundert mich auch immer.
Irgendwelche, hier guck mal,
Vibe-Coded-Projekt innerhalb von einem Tag zusammengewurschtelt.
Übrigens supportet die weitere Entwicklung mit Spenden.
Okay, Vibe-Coden kostet natürlich erst einmal Geld.
Die Tokens müssen ja irgendwie bezahlt werden.
Business-Preise.
Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen, ja.
Sehe ich ähnlich.
Gut, nach Mitwirken zu fragen und Testern zu fragen,
das finde ich jetzt persönlich nicht schlimm.
Aber irgendwie, was mit AI zusammengezimmert zu haben,
businessplaner am start zu haben ja meinetwegen aber dann noch irgendwie direkt nach spenden zu verändern das finde ich halt auch teilweise bisschen cringe ja
Wir haben übrigens ein neues emote, fällt mir da gerade auf
Was warum warum kann das hier mein ffz nicht chat was hier los
Warum kann das mein FFZ nicht?
Kann das hier?
Ja, das kann das hier.
Ich habe das letzte Mal in irgendeinem Chat gesehen.
Das muss ich reinmachen als Emote.
Fand ich so lustig.
Bei einer von meiner Cuts kann ich mir das Original so vorstellen.
Das ist aber halt auch so ein Bild, wo ich gleich...
Deswegen zeige ich es jetzt.
Wo ich gleich gedacht habe, ist das KI?
Ist das Bild KI, Leute?
Was meint ihr?
Deswegen habe ich das jetzt gezeigt, eigentlich gerade, wo wir beim Thema KI sind.
Meint ihr, das ist KI?
Ich könnte es mir durchaus vorstellen bei manchen Katzen, ja.
Aber es könnte auch durchaus KI sein.
Es gibt ja keinen gescheiten Test dafür, ob Bilder und Texte von KI sind.
Also, du kannst einen normal vom Mensch geschriebenen Text in der KI hinhalten, der sagt, oh, das ist KI.
Du kannst einen KI geschriebenen Text hinhalten, der sagt, nee, also.
Ist das hier?
Was bin ich da in der Ecke sehend?
Was ist das?
Ich erkenne es nicht.
Was ist das für ein Viech?
Ein Känguru oder was?
Ist das KI generiert?
Die KI wusste nicht, was für ein Tier es generieren will.
Oh, das kann Chatterino nicht,
diese Emote-Geschichte.
Lohnt es sich noch, für die Abschlussprüfung
zu lernen? Hab noch nichts gemacht,
schreibe die in einem Monat.
Also, du hast
überhaupt nichts verpasst.
Das Wichtigste
bei der Abschlussprüfung ist, die zwei Wochen
vor der Abschlussprüfung.
Genau. Das kriegst du ohne Probleme
auf die Reihe.
Du musst einfach nur alte Prüfungen machen
in Massen. Mach alte Prüfungen.
Weil das Wichtigste bei der
Abschlussprüfung, weil es wirklich steht, das mit Abstand Wichtigste bei der
Abschlussprüfung ist, sich rein zu
fühlen, schon im Vorfeld,
wie die IHK
Fragen stellt. Das ist das mit Abstand
Wichtigste.
Weil die
sind so dumm, diese Fragen.
immer und diese Art, wie das gefragt wird
und du kannst auch davon ausgehen,
dass
die Prüfung immer, also
mir fällt jetzt keine Abschlussprüfung ein, wo es nicht
größere Diskussionen drüber gab, dass
die sehr fehlerbehaftet war.
Also viele
merkwürdig gestellte Aufgaben, Aufgaben,
die dann im Nachhinein komplett gestrichen wurden,
die an sich falsch sind.
Ja.
Aber du hast noch massig Zeit.
Aber so langsam würde ich mir zumindest
schon nochmal die alten Prüfungen besorgen.
Kurz das putzen nochmal.
Genau, wie die IHK Fragen stellt und was sie darauf hören wollen.
Genau das ist es.
Ja, ja, easy, das schaffst du.
Wie gesagt, ich bin eh der Meinung,
wenn mich jemand fragen würde,
wer von beiden Leuten schafft die Prüfung?
Einer, der richtig gut in seinem Job ist,
richtig viel gelernt hat in der Ausbildung,
aber keine alten Prüfungen zur Vorbereitung macht,
versus einen, der gar keine Ahnung hat,
der die Ausbildung wahrscheinlich selbst nie gemacht hat,
aber sich einfach drei Wochen vor der Prüfung täglich vorbereitet.
Wer die Prüfung mit besserer Note schafft?
Ich tipp ganz klar auf den, der keine Ahnung hat, aber sich auf die Prüfung vorbereitet hat.
Aber das ist so.
Oder irgendjemand anderer hat Meinung.
Also ich bin fest davon überzeugt, das ist so.
So, ich wollte Package-Updates machen.
Warten wir hier gerade auf.
Ist halt so, ist dumm.
Ja, ist dumm.
Sehe ich auch so.
Es ist richtig dumm.
Aber es ist so.
So.
Updates und dann
Reboot.
Gibt es hier bei Jetbrains was Neues?
Check for Updates.
No Updates available.
Na gut.
Dann nicht.
Okay, wir müssen auf jeden Fall
rebooten, weil Kernel Updates
Was macht der Update Command in Cache.us?
Gute Frage, müssen wir mal nachgucken
Der macht auf jeden Fall
den Pac-Man Update und noch ein paar andere Sachen
wahrscheinlich
Ne, ich kann nicht gucken, weil ich muss erstmal Fish starten
Das ist ein Fish Alias
Äh
Hier, guck mal
update rap pacman minus su
pacman minus es sudow pacman minus es y also das war sie auch sonst vorhanden machen würde
ich habe gedacht er macht vielleicht noch das da hinterher oder so für
our packages aber ist anscheinend nicht so gut okay reboot recommended
warum bist du auf cash gewechselt ich weiß ja dass das frühes prozess das ist
ja auch in den arch und ich benutze immer noch einen arch linux jetzt aber irgendwie hat mir
hat also okay der erste grund warum cash ios weil es gehypt ist so das ist das ist eines der gründe
warum ich überhaupt gesagt habe ich guck mir das mal an da habe ich mir angeguckt fand das
eigentlich ziemlich sinnig vorkonfiguriert zwei sachen erstens das kde finde ich gut
Ähm
Lässt sich auch mit Shortcuts so gut benutzen
Dass ich eigentlich Tiling Window Manager Sachen kaum
Kaum vermisse
Ähm
Und was auch noch gut ist
Ist dass Snapshots und sowas mit eingerichtet sind
Fand ich eigentlich standardmäßig ganz gut
Und dachte ich mir so
Ey okay warum soll ich das alles selbst machen
Wenn ich auch CacheOS verwenden kann
Also ich
Der Hype hat mich angelockt
aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut und unter der haube ist es ein vollständiges archlinux also insofern gar kein problem
kann man immer noch alles mitmachen und warum sollte ich warum sollte ich das selbst einrichten
und kde ist wirklich nice hätte ich gar nicht gedacht ich bin ja tiling window manager fan aber ganz im ernst
wo ist der unterschied zwischen tiling window manager und einem kde wenn ich eh nur zwei anwendungen im fullscreen habe
Ich hab ja ganz selten mal sowas hier
Und dann geht das immer noch
Aber da hab ich den Shortcut vergessen dazu
Man kann das bei KDE
Es gibt so ein Tiling-Ding bei KDE
Dass der das auch anordnen kann
Nein, ich bin nicht mehr Elgato-Sponsor
Ich war vor Jahren auf YouTube mal Elgato-Sponsor
Können wir das anschauen?
Dann muss ich erstmal checken, was das für ein Video ist.
Stille.
AGI ist hier. Das Video habe ich geguckt.
Das fand ich jetzt nicht so toll.
Da ging es halt darum, dass irgendein Unternehmen definiert hat,
dass wir jetzt AGI haben.
Aber, naja.
Kann man sich drüber streiten.
Ja, die wollen halt, dass Leute
Das System einfach benutzen können
Ich finde ein Update alias gar nicht so verkehrt für
Weil, was machen Leute instinktiv
Wenn sie das System updaten wollen
Update eintippen
Und es funktioniert
Wer was anderes will, kann es ja auch so eintippen
Ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht
Moment, habe ich jetzt, ja ich habe rebooted, ne
Oh, erstmal eine Runde
Askiquarium durchlaufen lassen
Allein schon, dass du
CacheOS täglich benutzt, hast du wahrscheinlich
mehr gelernt, als die meisten Windows-User
in der gesamten Zeit, als sie Windows
benutzt haben.
Was war denn für dich der Grund, warum du gesagt hast,
du willst kein Windows mehr?
Das frage ich immer gerne,
weil habe ich schon unterschiedlichste Sachen gehört.
Aber bei den meisten
Leuten geht halt die Entwicklung von Microsoft
auf den Sack. Beziehungsweise wie
Microsoft Windows behandelt
die letzten Jahre über.
Ich muss übrigens gerade nochmal hier
5002. Warum
5002, keine Ahnung.
Hier haben wir mal ein Board einblenden,
dass ich zur Not auch hier Overlay-
Bilder hab.
Das können wir doch eigentlich.
Wartet mal, das schieben wir mal auf Desktop 4.
Oh Mist, ich hab das nicht eingerichtet.
Äh.
Chat.
Ich will das hier auf Desktop 4
schieben. Das hab ich noch nicht
eingerichtet. Kann das sein?
Oh ne.
Äh.
Wo ist denn der Knopf zum Verschieben?
Den gibt es nicht.
Der ist weg.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Settings.
Shortcuts.
Jetzt habe ich den noch nicht eingerichtet.
Anwendung verschieben.
Äh.
Window Management vielleicht.
Und jetzt irgendwie Desktop.
Switch to Desktop.
Window to Desktop 1.
Das so.
Window to Desktop 2.
Window to Desktop 3.
Window to Desktop 4.
Okay.
Ah, ja.
Excellent.
Desktop.
Ja.
Oder einfach
Also erstmal mag ich Privatsphäre
Was mich darüber gezogen hat
War, dass mir Windows im Idle zu viel
Okay, ja gut, mittlerweile läuft der da auch
Laufen da noch 80 Dinger oder so im Background
Und wie funktioniert VR-Spielen unter Linux?
Das hab ich noch gar nicht gehört von Leuten
funktioniert das gut wie ist der vr support zu unterlinux da hätte ich
jetzt eigentlich eher gedacht dass das ein gebiet ist wo probleme machen
Also ganz weg ist die Erkältung noch nicht
So
Gut Leute
Was machen wir jetzt? Jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was auf GitHub so trendet
ShitHub
GitHub
Trends.
Trending.
So, wir skippen wieder
die ganzen AI-Projekte.
Außer irgendwas finde ich wirklich spannend.
Kann es sein, dass
CachyOS nicht booten kann, wenn
ähm, Secure Boot an ist.
Das kann immer sein, äh,
vielleicht musst du Keys enrollen,
dass das richtig funktioniert.
Ähm, da hab ich ehrlich gesagt
keine Erfahrung mit.
Kann ich dir, da musst du googeln.
Aber das kann schon sein, ja.
Wobei, ähm,
es ja normalerweise da eine
Meldung kommt, wenn das nicht booten kann,
wegen Secure Boot.
Chat
Chat play Stalker File oder sowas
Twitch Chat
Chat play Stalker File
Also es könnte schon
Es könnte schon sein
Du kannst ja Secure Boot mal ausschalten und gucken, ob es dann funktioniert.
Dann kannst du es ja relativ schnell ausschließen, ob es damit ein Problem gibt oder nicht.
Mit VR muss man ein bisschen gucken, Probleme über Sound zu bekommen.
Okay.
Oh.
Aber ich denke, da wird sich wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Jahren noch mehr tun.
Je mehr Leute auf Linux switchen,
je größer ist ja auch der Anreiz für die Hersteller
für, dass das
ordentlich supported wird.
Wenn es da
nicht irgendwelche Wayland-Probleme gibt oder so.
Moin, war gerade schon
zwei Stunden spazieren, zehn Kilometer.
Nice.
Ist auch ganz gute Geschwindigkeit zum Spazieren,
zwei Stunden, zehn Kilometer.
das ist ein 12 12 pace oder 12 pace 12 12 minuten pro kilometer weil ein sechser pace ist kilometer
in der stunde und dann ist ein 12 pace zwei stunden zehn kilometer das ist recht das ist
nicht super schnell gelaufen, aber das ist ganz
Es ist auch nicht super zügig, aber ganz
zackig gelaufen. Also nicht so
Oma-mäßig gelaufen.
Oh ja, ähm
Ich habe da bisher immer einen Bogen drum gemacht und ich habe hier bei der Kiste, hier auf der Linux-Kiste, habe ich Secure Boot ausgeschaltet.
Oder mal umgedreht gefragt, habe ich Secure Boot ausgeschaltet? Wie kann man unter Linux überhaupt gucken, ob man Secure Boot anhat?
Linux check if Secure Boot is enabled.
Monka S.
Erkältungsstelz.
Moment, was zum...
Äh...
Wait a minute, Alter.
Wie kryptisch...
Wie kryptisch möchte es sein,
um herauszubekommen,
ob Secure Boot eingeschaltet ist,
Alter?
Okay, was?
S-B-C-T-L?
Hab ich nicht. Was ist das?
Secure Boot Key Manager.
Ja gut, wenn ich das nicht installiert habe, Leute, dann ist wahrscheinlich kein Secure Boot aktiviert, oder?
Secure Boot Key Directory doesn't exist, not signing.
Okay, würde ich sagen.
Würde ich sagen, ist nicht installiert.
Was, Cat?
TPM 2.0, die weiß er, das sagt jetzt er.
SB
CTL Status.
Secure Boot
Disabled. Okay.
Dann kann ich den Kameramann wieder aninstallen.
Yes.
Ich habe übrigens gelernt,
dass man Secure Boot nicht ausschalten sollte,
wenn man Windows übrigens im Toolboot hat.
Wenn man das ausschaltet, fehlt man die Keys und kriegt
das Windows nicht mehr gestartet. Selbst wenn du
danach wieder Keys enrollst, nicht?
Sollte man, sollte Windows
nicht starten, wenn Secure Boot aus ist?
Einfach so?
Okay, keine Ahnung, ich weiß schon, warum ich den
Krempel nicht anhab.
Wobei, auf meinem Host-System, also
Haussystem. Auf meiner Windows-Kiste hier
habe ich Secure Boot an. Braucht man ja mittlerweile
für irgendwelche Anti-Cheat-Sachen und sowas.
Sackt halt auch mal richtig hart.
Also, so, lass mal gucken. Was trendet denn
auf GitHub so heute?
Open Viking
trendet.
Open Source Context
Database
Ach so, ah!
Das ist eine History quasi.
Das ist quasi ein Gehirn sozusagen
für KI.
Context Database.
Warum gab es so was
nicht schon früher? Eigentlich ist das so eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Okay.
Cloud Plugins.
Demos.
Vibecode. Okay.
Äh.
AI. AI. AI.
AI.
Moment ist das Premiere? Heute waren alle, komplett alle Trending Projekte AI. Also es
ist auch nur today, ich will ja weekly.
Was hat mir GitHub da gerade eingeblendet?
Was war hier gerade eingeblendet?
Wie habe ich das gemacht?
Weiß man nicht so genau.
Simple and Universal.
Okay, AI.
Es steht hier zwar nicht direkt, aber ich bin relativ sicher, AI.
Ey, ey.
Ich glaube, du hast gerade halluziniert.
Nee, da war doch eben irgendwas eingeblendet.
Was war denn das?
Ich beweise es euch.
Gut, wir haben ja History
So
Oh man, das ist doch zu weit
Das da
Was war das?
Ach, das ist das, weil ich das Track und Drop habe
von wegen ich habe halluziniert leute was ihr da wieder verzeugt erzählt ihr habt selektiv
nicht aufgepasst das war weil ich das track und drop habe jetzt verstehe ich das ich habe
quasi so gemacht und mein browser war der meinung er will das irgendwie ihr guckt
Sie muss er
Ich habe dazu ein paar Verschwörungsvideos geguckt. Das ist der Wahnsinn,
die Leute haben so Dachschaden teilweise.
Also, warte mal. Scheiße, ich muss übel susten.
MonkaS
Okay, so.
Wieder am Start.
Chat.
Kommt nicht auf die Idee danach zu googeln.
Ihr flippt aus dem Kopf, wie bescheuert die Leute sind.
Aber nur mal eine Frage.
Habt ihr schon mal das Wort Mandela-Effekt oder Mandela-Effekt gehört?
Das ist so ein Ding, was Verschwörungstheorie-Leute lieben, das.
Damit ist gemeint,
So, das kollektive Falscherinnern an bestimmte Ereignisse. Ja, zum Beispiel, was sagt Darth Vader zu Luke Skywalker? Luke, ich bin dein Vater. In Wirklichkeit hat er ja was anderes gesagt.
Und die Leute sagen dann, Moment, so und jetzt kommt die Verschwörungstheorie dazu. Die Verschwörungstheorie zum Mandela-Effekt sagt, eigentlich ist es wirklich so passiert, wie es die Leute im Kopf haben, aber irgendeine, was auch immer dahinter stehende Macht manipuliert die Welt.
Also nicht, die Leute erinnern sich einfach nur falsch, sondern die Leute erinnern sich richtig und die Welt mit manipuliert.
Das ist die Verschwörungstheorie dahinter.
Keck Alu, ja, aber richtig Keck Alu.
Da habe ich ein Video geguckt von einem, der hat Google Earth aufgemacht und hat gesagt,
er erinnert sich genau die Küstenlinie vom, keine Ahnung, Golf of Mexico.
Die war früher anders.
Und ihr erinnert euch doch auch alle dran, dass die Küstenlinie früher anders war.
Das heißt, ähm, ähm, ne und in dem Video hat er dann gesagt, genau,
Australien war ja früher auch, war ja auch viel näher früher, ähm, an Asien dran.
Daran kann er sich genau erinnern.
Und dann hat er in dem Video, da hab ich mich so, hab ich mich so kaputt gelacht in dem Video.
hat er gesagt,
Australia has moved.
I repeat, Australia has
moved.
Alter, die Leute sind so
durch im Kopf, Mann.
Und er hat es halt komplett
geglaubt.
Es gibt schon
verrückte Leute, Alter.
Dieser Verschwörungstheorie oder...
Wie soll man sagen?
G-Bait-Verschwörungstheorie, der kann nicht sogar was abgewinnen.
Es gibt doch da dieses Meme.
Vor 2015 oder inklusive 2015 alles gut.
Dann Harambe und danach alles schlecht.
Der kann nicht was abgewinnen.
Da glaube ich dran.
Das glaube ich, dass das so ist.
Ja.
Wobei, nee.
Ich bin ja Wubblos, ganz vergessen.
Aber schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
So, Alter, das ist ja schlimm gerade.
Ich muss die ganze Zeit husten.
Aber ich merke, dass meine Erkältung schon viel besser ist, weil da löst sich immer gefühlt irgendwie 3 Liter Schleim oder so, wenn ich husten muss.
Ich weiß so genau, wolltet ihr es wahrscheinlich gar nicht wissen.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Ich wollte noch gucken, was sonst noch so auf GitHub trendet.
Schleim-Sauce.
also was trennen sonst noch auflegen gucken was im schab umfeld trennt vielleicht nicht ganz so viel
modern fly app layout app von bild ist flut was zum teufel ist denn jetzt schon wieder flut design
2 microsoft ändert das ja aber auch wirklich laufend ich mal guckt euch diesen hier sieht
man es eigentlich ganz gut wobei man müsste sich das ist der wahnsinn was zum teufel ist
jetzt schon wieder schon fluent design 2
aha das absolut nicht sagen wie ohne wie bescheid kann man eine übersicht seite
machen
ohne beispiele overview components hier card das ist flut design 2 ganz toll
ja genau wenn das ja momentan mal das ist ja schon fünf jahre her dieser post
das ist mittlerweile noch schlimmer das ist ja mittlerweile immer flut design
zwei schon
mein lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist immer das hier guckt mal
kassemals change das sind so ganz also also erstens war dass man dieses fenster
hier in keinster weise wie es heißen kann
Aber da sind richtige, richtige Hi-Res-Sachen drin hier teilweise.
Guck mal hier.
Massive Hi-Res-Icons.
Hier, beste, oder?
Finde ich auch.
Richtig zeitgemäße Icons hier, oder?
Äh.
Kann es sein, dass das nicht mal mehr funktioniert?
Ah, jetzt. Okay.
guck mal, das zoomt gar nicht
das, guck mal, seht ihr
das kann nicht zoomen, das ist zu schlecht
zum zoomen, das Icon, das bleibt immer
gleich groß
aber kleiner machen kann ich's, aber größer
nicht
übrigens
das laggt
das laggt as fuck hier
dieses Icons vergrößern und verkleinern
das laggt sowas von
das war, by the way, unter Windows
1995 war das Instant, ne?
Nur mal so nebenbei erwähnt.
Das muss ich jetzt übrigens wieder rückgängig machen,
weil ansonsten finde ich das nie im Leben wieder.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem und dem?
Chat, seht ihr da einen Unterschied?
Ich nicht.
Es gibt zwar immer den gleichen Ordner.
Na gut.
Ach guck mal, der eine hier oben hat eher so einen
Da hat der noch so einen weißen Strich
Und der hier nicht
Blue und 1 und 2
Vielleicht, ja
Aber das hier trifft es eigentlich echt ganz gut
Und es sind noch viel mehr Designs drunter
Ich bin der Meinung
Windows XP, könnt ihr mir was sagen
was eurer Meinung nach
Windows Peak Design war
ich bin der Meinung, Windows XP war
Peak Design unter Windows
das war das letzte Mal, dass Windows
aus einem Guss war, Windows XP
das letzte Mal
danach ging es los mit Aero
und
inkonsistenten
Sachen
Äh, Vista
hat ein bisschen die Grundlage
für das gelegt, wie es heute ist
Also von den
unter, unter, drunter liegenden Technologien
Die Fenster gerendert werden und sowas
Das kam ja viel, das kam ja mit Vista
Übrigens, ich bin auch der Meinung
dass das Startmenü, der Grund, warum das Startmenü von Windows in JavaScript und React programmiert ist, liegt daran, weil AI besser darin ist, JavaScript zu generaten, als irgendwelche Low-Level-Windows-AP-Geschichten.
Oder
Das könnte durchaus sein
Ich meine wir reden hier von
Von
Moment
Den hier
So
Ich muss unbedingt mehr trinken
Weil ich nicht so viel wusste
Heute gehe ich auf jeden Fall eine Runde joggen nachher
Auch wenn mir noch die Nase läuft
Ich bin ja wieder fit genug
Ich war jetzt eine Woche
In der Woche habe ich gar nichts mehr gemacht
Ich merke das richtig
Hat Microsoft nicht schon bestätigt, dass die alles Vibe coden?
Die haben nicht, glaube ich, bestätigt, dass sie alles Vibe coden
Die haben aber gesagt, dass irgendwie ein Großteil ihrer Sachen mittlerweile gevibe codet sind
wieso meinst du dass ich schon zu vista zeiten gewalt code haben
du meinst weil es damals schon so kacke war oder wie
ich bin nicht mehr großartig krank das geht mir läuft bloß noch die
nass das ist so der rest der raus muss
so sieht's aus also so sieht es hoffentlich nicht aus
unter windows in zug mal gucken jetzt mal angenommen windows 12 kommt raus
meint ihr dann windows 12 kommt mit einem einheitlichen aus einem guss
design oder windows 12 wird ein neues design system mitbringen und alle anderen mitschleppen
was meint ihr ist wahrscheinlicher
neu ist ja ja neues design auf jeden fall aber auch alle alten sachen aus einem guss
oder eher
neues Design
und alle anderen sind immer noch da.
Never, dass das irgendwann nochmals in einem Kurs ist.
Glaube ich nämlich auch nicht.
Windows 98 UI?
Ey, ich glaube,
Ohne Mist, ich glaube, das hier ist Windows 98 UI, oder?
Das hier
Ich glaube, das ist Windows 98
Dieses Fenster hier
Oder noch 95
Ja, okay, das kann natürlich auch sein
So, mal gucken, ob es wieder Updates gibt.
Ich meine, wir haben immerhin schon eine Viertelstunde nicht mehr geupdatet.
Excellent, ne, gibt nix.
Ich hab schon ein paar Versuche gesehen,
ähm,
Custom-Desktops unter Windows zu implementieren.
Bin mir nicht sicher, wie gut das dann im Endeffekt auch funktioniert hat.
Es gab mal ein K...
Stimmt, ja, richtig.
Benutzt du Caching-OS?
Du meinst Cache-OS heißt das, ja.
Cache-OS.
Mittlerweile Cache-OS.
Vorher war ich auf einem
was ich...
Raw-Art-Linux und hab alles
selbst gemacht, aber mittlerweile hab ich Cache-OS
am Start seit ein paar Wochen
mit KDE auch, nicht mit Tiling Window Manager.
Und ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut.
Er ist immer noch Arch, by the way.
Cache ist ja immer noch Arch.
Also hier, guckt auf dem Desktop Windows,
auf dem Desktop Linux.
Beste Kombination
beider Welten, wie ich finde.
Und man muss wirklich sagen,
auf diesem Mini-PC hier,
CacheOS läuft richtig gut.
übrigens chat ich habe mich dazu entschieden mein drittes nass auch noch zu behalten
darf man da sagen i use arch klar bei cache us darfst du das sagen ich behalte mein drittes
nass auch noch das kriegt dann der max dem habe ich da versprochen er kriegt das nass
wenn wir uns das fertig angeguckt haben dann kriegt ihr kriegt ihr ein besseres
Nee, kein Black Server.
Betreiben werde ich davon nur eins.
Nämlich das Minisforum.
Ja klar kriegt der das.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich behalte das.
Der kriegt das bessere, das neuere.
Mit dem ein Performance-Score mehr.
So.
Okay.
Ich wollte ja noch hier kurz gucken, was trendet auf GitHub bei C Sharp.
Uni-Get-UI.
Graphical Interface for your Package Managers.
Was ist denn das?
Was ist das?
Das ist ein grafisch...
Ah, guck mal.
Das ist gar nicht mal übel.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Das gefällt mir.
Devolutions.
Monka S.
Uniget UI enters its next chapter with Devolutions.
Das hat auch ein Marketing-Mensch geschrieben, oder?
Ah, die wurden gekauft.
Okay, wird das jetzt Shit?
Ah, KI-Bilder.
Nice.
GG.
Ja, aber das klingt tatsächlich mal nach einer nutzbaren Lösung.
Für Windows.
WinGet ist ja mittlerweile
schon eine ganze
Weile unter Windows dabei.
Aber mal Frage an euch, Chat.
Benutzt ihr aktiv WinGet?
Also diesen
Windows CLI Terminal Manager, äh,
Package Manager?
Letztes Textprogramm.
So schlimm.
Also ich benutze
das eigentlich auch nicht.
Du meinst nicht Winget, was meinst du denn sonst?
Das hier oder was?
Uniget?
Okay.
GUI Client for Windows Support X-Ray und Singbox.
Was?
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das ist.
humanizer humanizer mit soll oder netz von manipuliert das kenne ich das ist
eine richtig gute library wer dort nicht verwendet und mal so sachen formatieren
muss wie date time zu 63 days ago und sowas ist richtig gut hier die library
habe ich auch schon ein paar mal verwendet kann man wirklich nur empfehlen
wenn man sowas machen muss.
Aber der kann halt total viel.
Guck, kann dir zum Beispiel
ein Timespan von Milliseconds
humanize to weeks.
Man kann es einstellen in Weeks, Days, Hours,
Seconds. Das ist das richtig
nice. Also wenn man
Einheiten oder Werte
mit Einheiten passend
formatieren muss, so dass es sich
gut lesen lässt, ist Humanizer wirklich top.
.NET Runtime
x hyper wie der excalibur auf hyper was für ein ding
ich check's nicht easy to use configuration tool for advanced hyper
features
Achso Hyper V, MonkaS, Alter, hör mal bloß auf.
Spina Chinesen, gui.
Ganz wichtig dieses komische Wetter-Wetter-Icon da unten, was auch kein Mensch je benutzt
hat.
Okay.
Äh, ich bin froh, dass Hyper-V
bisher an mir vorbeigegangen ist.
Und ich werde auch
da alles dran setzen, dass es in Zukunft
an mir vorbeigeht.
Bulk Crap Uninstaller.
Okay, das klingt auch
nicht so unanübel.
Looking for Maintainers.
Oh, okay.
Aber warum braucht beispielsweise Fubar einen Uninstaller?
Hä?
Was nutzt du jetzt?
Ich benutze auf dem Desktop vor allem der Workstation, was leider unter der Haube Hyper-V ist mittlerweile.
unter Windows, wenn du diese
VM Extensions oder wie das heißt, unter Windows anhast. Also ich benutze VMware
und KVM
und auf der Arbeit, tja, VMware, was sonst?
Weil
Broadcom braucht Geld
Und es gibt keine gescheite Alternative
So.
Next.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
C-Sharp, SDK.
Unity, AI.
Was ist das denn?
Lightweight Open Source Control Tool
for Asus.
Asus Laptops.
Okay, ich habe keine Asus Laptop.
Aber cool, dass es sowas gibt.
Interesting.
Es ist die Sharp Game Engine.
Moment, ich dachte, die stehen alle auf Unity.
Wobei, Unity hat eine saumäßig alte
C Sharp Version, oder?
War da nicht was?
Ist das C Sharp in Unity nicht ur-ur-alt?
Ist die Sharp 5
oder irgendwie sowas?
Bist du umgestiegen auf
Cache US?
Kann man so umgestiegen denn ich meine es ist ja immer noch ein arzt unter der haube ich bin umgestiegen von meiner
arch linux
teiling window manager vm
auf einen
caches mini pc
Das ist jetzt hier ein mini pc
Mini pc
mit 4 die richtige hs
die cpu
mit Prozent
in einem achtkehren
achtkehren reisen 16 Platz
aber der teiling window manager den der den vermisse ich gar nicht so sehr
großartig weil guck mal
was hatte ich auf meinem teiling window manager
du hast du vor allem laufen die die die die die die die sich dann hast du
Auf meinem Tiling Window Manager habe ich Browser im Fullscreen gehabt auf Desktop 1,
Terminal im Fullscreen auf Desktop 2.
Das habe ich schon mal, genauso unter KDE.
Auf Desktop 3 und 4 habe ich dann Editor IDE oder sowas,
aber meistens eine Anwendung im Fullscreen.
Manchmal zwei.
So, und das kann man auch wunderbar mit KDE machen.
Und KDE selbst ist halt so ein schönes, nettes, komplettes Paket,
da ich gar keinen Bock habe, hier an
irgendwas anderem ewig rumzufummeln.
Hyperland habe ich nur mal ganz kurz ausprobiert.
Ist auch benutzbar.
Ich wollte
Mango-WM mal eine Weile ausprobieren.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich finde KDE ist
einfach ein gutes Paket.
Wie es den Minis vor Umlass geht,
das steht hier neben mir
und wartet drauf, dass endlich
sein Samba-Share eingerichtet wird
im Stream. Und zwar
diesmal im LXT-Container, um zu gucken, ob das
noch schneller ist als in der in der media world vor allem weil ich mache das auch heute mittag
weil ich merke dass immer wisst ihr wisst ihr eigentlich dass der stream quasi therapeutisch
verordnet ist vielleicht bisschen übertrieben ausgesprochen jetzt aber ich habe ja bis ende
letzten jahres eine therapie gemacht so für kopf und gehirn und wie heißt das richtig
Für die Psyche, für die Psyche, ja. Und mein Therapeut hat gesagt, ich soll öfters mal streamen, weil das immer gut ist, wenn man sich im Kopf so festgefahren hat, für die Seele, genau.
Wenn man sich so festgefahren hat im Kopf, dann braucht man manchmal ein bisschen Ablenkung und es muss größer als eine Viertelstunde sein, dass das wirklich auch nachhaltig ist.
und da wäre doch streamen optimal also es ist quasi therapeutisch verordneter stream
werden die kosten für den stream der kranken hast karten krankenkasse getragen und wenn
der stream kostet nichts das team bringt sogar ein bisschen was auch für der
therapeut therapeut ist gesucht ich hoffe nicht dass er überhaupt ein channel kennt
Hoffe ich nicht.
Wobei, ist ja nicht schlimm.
Hilft es? Ja.
Gerade wenn es ein bisschen schlechter geht wieder,
hilft das, ja.
Ist nicht schlecht.
Was machst du?
Trunas Setup mit den Minis? Warum?
Warum?
Warum Trunas?
Du meinst, anstatt
dem Open Media Vault mal Trunas in der
VM? Das funktioniert nicht.
Weil Trunas möchte ja die Festplatten
selbst verwalten.
Und
ich verwalte ja die
Festplatten über ZFS auf dem Proxmox Host
und reiche im Endeffekt nur einen Ordner weiter an die VM.
Und ich glaube, das geht mit Proxmox nicht gescheit.
Ist auch sogar gut, oder?
Da sind die Leute vorgewarnt, wie schlecht C++ ist.
Ich mache das über Proxmox, ja.
Hast du eine VM auf deinem neuen...
Ich muss die ganze Zeit husten. Was ist das denn?
ok hast du auf der vor also vor allem auf der 9 das system laufen mit cash
us ich habe eine mini pc hier einen link ca 7 und ding hier das teil hier
und da läuft erst drauf und wie ich das ganze gemacht habe es folgendermaßen das ist wirklich
big brain finde ich also ich finde das ist wirklich wo er da habe ich habe ich nicht
mal sogar so ein big brain im ist das und zwar guck mal wie das funktioniert also unter der unter
der haube ich zeige euch mal wie das ist kommt man ich habe zwei ich habe zwei windows desktops
desktop 1 und desktop 2 so auf desktop 1 ist das was ihr gerade seht auf desktop 2 ist ein
fullscreen obs so funktioniert folgendermaßen ich switch mal rüber guck mal das was ihr hier
eigentlich als linux seht ist letztendlich meine elgato capture card in einem zweiten obs im
fullscreen guckt deswegen bewegt sich jetzt auch hier dass das hier bin ich auch beim windows über
OBS. Ich capture
quasi den Output vom Mini-PC
mit 240
Hertz.
Ich habe
eine Elgato 4K Pro, die kann
1080p mit 240 Hertz capturen.
Ich capture das mit 240
Hertz vom Mini-PC
und dann habe ich das
Gear quasi im OBS
drin und habe hier nur das OBS als Fullscreen.
Oh, so funzt das.
Und
Das funktioniert
Also
Zu 98%
Lagfrei
Du merkst keinen Unterschied
Ob du das hier über die Capture Card siehst
Oder direkt über den Monitor
Es ist 98% Latency Free
Also du merkst es nicht
Also ich hab überhaupt keine Probleme
Und ihr wisst ich bin super empfindlich
Was irgendwelche Lagging, Tearing oder sonst was angeht
Tearing
oder irgendwelches gelaggige, ruckelige
Pixel, kriege ich Anfälle.
Ist nicht so. Also
also nicht wirklich Anfälle,
ich kriege mich auf.
Ist super. So. Und jetzt ist natürlich
die Frage, wie kommt man mit der Tastatur
vom, also
wie schaffe ich es mit der gleichen Tastatur
und der gleichen Maus, sowohl
mein Windows zu bedienen, als auch
mein Linux zu bedienen.
Vielleicht fällt euch schon was auf. Guckt mal, wenn ich
hier umschalte fällt euch auf dass irgendwie mit der mauszeiger dass er so
ein bisschen bisschen die late ist der mauszeiger guckt mal hier ein bisschen
bisschen die lei guck mal hier erscheint er zuerst switch drüber hier ist er
wieder weg also man sieht der mauszeiger ist ein bisschen die leiten das liegt
daran ich habe hier das flow laufen das flow ist eine tastatur maus sharing
software die habe ich hier auf meinem windows pc laufen und die habe ich hier auf meiner linux
kiste laufen im prinzip teile ich tastatur und maus über diese software zwischen zwei pcs so
und dann habe ich dann habe ich in makro in meiner logitech software die einfach abfahrt
langsam ist mittlerweile.
Warum auch immer.
Bestimmt, weil es eine eklige Elektron-
Anwendung ist, die suckt.
Dann habe ich
ein Makro.
Hier.
Und zwar ein Makro,
was folgendermaßen drückt. Also ich habe hier
auf F1 und F2
habe ich jeweils ein Makro drauf.
Und zwar
linke Windows-Taste
plus Control
und dann den Pfeil nach rechts
und dann Alt-A drücken.
Und umgedreht habe ich hier noch ein zweites Makro.
Alt-Ö drücken,
linke Windows-Taste,
Control und nach rechts.
Also, fangen wir erstmal an.
Linke Windows-Taste nach links und rechts.
Also Control, Windows-Taste ist Desktop-Switchen.
Guckt, Desktop-Switchen.
Windows-Desktop-Switchen.
Zwischen Desktop 1 und Desktop 2.
Ihr seht es ja unten in der Mitte,
steht es ja auch Desktop 1, Desktop 2.
Control-A und Control-Ö
ist wiederum
ein Shortcut
hier drinnen
und zwar
switcht Control-A
zu meinem Desktop und Control-Ö
switcht zu CacheOS
so und das jetzt alles zusammen
heißt
ich drücke jetzt F2
es switcht auf den zweiten Desktop
wo mein OBS im Fullscreen läuft
und den Mini-PC gecaptischen Output
über die Capture Card anzeigt
und dann drückt es
Alt-Ö
was heißt
hier Switch, guck hier seht ihr es ja auch
Switch auf Cache OS
und das dann alles zusammen
sieht dann so aus, als hätte ich hier quasi Windows und Linux
parallel, dabei ist da ein bisschen Trick 17
dabei
Pfeifert, oder?
ich finde das setup ich finde es next level richtig high IQ setup
wie hast du Tastatur switch gemacht mit mit deskflow
hier
Deskflow macht den Tastatursharing
zwischen 4M und Windows
was kostet
der Mini-PC?
den gibt es nicht mehr, ich habe mir den Mini-PC nicht dafür
gekauft ursprünglich, by the way
ich habe mir den als Emulator-Kiste oder als
Bastel-Emulator-Kiste gekauft
ähm
den gibt es ja mittlerweile nicht mehr
Da tut es auch, Leute, da tut es deutlich günstigere Kisten dafür.
Gibt es vielleicht ein SR8 oder so mittlerweile schon?
589 Dollar kostet die neuere Version davon.
Aber wie gesagt, da tun es auch deutlich, deutlich günstigere Kisten für die Linux, als Linux-Kiste.
Guck mal, bei AliExpress
Bei den China-Chinesen
Kostet der PC nur 525 Dollar
Okay, AliExpress ist halt immer richtig eklig zu benutzen
Von der Webseite her
Äh
Okay
Alter
Die Seite, man, die macht mich
BTF
Gibt's das jetzt nicht mehr, oder was?
Mal weg, AliExpress
Ey, keine Ahnung
AliExpress macht wieder AliExpress Dinge
Ah
Ist anscheinend hier auch nicht mehr lieferbar
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Drucker, geh mal weg
Ups, jetzt macht er es da drin auf
Das soll er ja gar nicht
Ja, sowas geht auch klar
Sowas geht auch klar für eine Linux-Kiste
Jaja
Ist auch nicht verkehrt
Könnte man vielleicht noch 8GB dazu reinpappen
Aber ansonsten
Geht auch das hier klar
Wie viele Kerne hat das Ding?
Also man findet
Mini-PCs findet man wirklich genug
6 Kerne, ja vollkommen in Ordnung
Ah guck mal hier
Die Katz
Ja 8 Gig ist preislich
Aktuell noch
Durchaus möglich, ja
Also ich finde das Minisforum richtig gut.
Aber ja, das kostet natürlich,
hast schon recht, ein bisschen teurer.
Okay, also.
By the way, ich hab mal eine Frage.
Wo ist eigentlich der Unterschied von LXC-Container zu OCI-Container,
abgesehen von öffentlichen Unterschieden?
Ja, das ist schon...
Das ist auch ein großer Unterschied.
Also, ich würde sagen, aus Anwendersicht, der größte Unterschied ist,
OCI-Container oder ich nenne es mal Docker-Container,
das, was die meisten Leute unter Container so verstehen,
ist dafür gedacht, eine Anwendung auszuführen.
Wohingegen LXC-Container in Init starten, also Systemd starten,
und ein vollwertiges Betriebssystem im Container laufen haben.
Ein vollwertiges Betriebssystem stimmt nicht,
weil der Kern ist natürlich immer noch vom Host,
aber ein vollständiges wie nennt man das user system also außer außerdem können also ich denke
also es ist egal ob das technisch hundertprozentig richtig ist aber ich sag's trotzdem mal in dem
lxc container läuft quasi ein komplettes linux und im container nur ein prozess aber der host
kernel scheren sich beide user user land genau was quasi alles außerdem kölner was zu einem
vollständigen linux gehört in einem lxc container laufen wohingegen in dem container in der regel
nur ein prozess läuft das heißt wenn du so was haben willst wie ich möchte eigentlich
dem db an server haben um darauf mehrere sachen zu installieren dann ist ein lxc container natürlich
deutlich besser wenn du was haben willst wie ich möchte eine anwendung laufen lassen und
halten fertiges container image wenn ich der staat läuft die anwendung dann eher eine docker container
also lxt container ist quasi eine eher containerisierung auf betriebssystem ebene
und container ist containerisierung auf anwendungsebene glaubt so könnte man das
am besten zusammenfassen.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Was haben wir denn hier auf YouTube so zu bieten
heute?
Er sorgt für Ordnung.
Open Source AI Tools.
Oh, nee, kein AI, stell's jetzt.
Was ist das hier?
Oh, yeah, Nextcloud.
Da muss ich flamen, Leute. Ihr wisst, ich bin kein
Nextcloud-Fan.
Aber vielleicht
Vielleicht bekehren sie mich ja.
Ich glaub's aber nicht.
Technisch sind sich alle Containerisierungssachen ähnlich,
weil die ja die gleichen Kernelfunktionalitäten benutzen.
Die benutzen C-Groups, die benutzen Namespaces und noch ein paar kleine Sachen.
Das machen ja alle.
Also unter der Haube...
Ein Container in dem Sinn existieren ja eh nicht.
Unter Container werden verschiedene Kernelfunktionalitäten
plus ein paar User-Tools zusammengefasst.
Warum wackelt immer mal zwischendurch eigentlich meine Maus?
Das hab ich ja jetzt schon ein paar Mal aufgefallen.
Ab so macht die Maus immer mal so.
Das bin nicht ich.
Ich hab keine hier irgendwelche epileptischen Anfälle oder so.
Immer mal die Maus zwischendurch die wackelt.
Der Chat ist...
Ach so.
Jetzt versteh ich das.
Jetzt macht es Sinn.
Na klar.
ihr seid das logisch
So, also was haben wir denn hier?
Sie wollen uns ein bisschen Nextcloud schmackhaft machen.
Schauen wir mal.
hier ich mache nextcloud video calls bearbeitet tabellen mit mehreren leuten
gleichzeitig also bevor wir uns das video angucken
ich bin ja der meinung oder muss das anders sagen
meine erfahrungen mit nextcloud die ich bisher gemacht habe fand ich nicht
sonderlich überzeugend
also für mich hat sich nextcloud immer ein bisschen so dargestellt wie ein
großes Sammelsurium aus mehr oder weniger fertig und unfertigen Komponenten.
Und so richtig überzeugt hat es mich noch nie.
Also mal gucken was da jetzt rauskommt.
Und ich habe es immer wieder probiert, so ist es gar nicht.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Ich schicke GIFs in den Chat mit meinen 3003 Kollegen und das Ganze sieht gut aus, ist einfach zu bedienen, open source und kostenlos.
Hä? Hieß es nicht immer, das ist kein richtiger Alternativ zu Microsoft?
Also das Problem, was ich jetzt gleich schon mal sehe, als Teams-Alternative ist,
Wie ist es denn mit der Zusammenarbeit jetzt so arbeitsgruppenübergreifend?
Also sprich, in Teams haben wir beispielsweise öfters einmal in der Woche, nehmen wir das mal als Beispiel, haben wir einmal in der Woche einen Call mit einem Hersteller, der für unsere Software programmiert.
programmiert.
So, und das machen wir
über Teams. Die werden halt einfach zu diesem
Teams-Meeting eingeladen.
Geht das mit Nextcloud Talk
auch gescheit? Oder
brauchen die dann auch Nextcloud?
Geht mittlerweile recht gut.
Also, was ich immer ganz schlimm finde, ist,
wenn ich zu irgendwelchen Zoom-Meetings
eingeladen werde.
Zoom macht mich immer
komplett fertig.
Zumal es irgendwie nicht richtig im Browser funktioniert bei mir.
Ich habe da immer Probleme mit.
gemieteten Server bei einem
Hoster. Die große Frage, ist das
gefrickelt? Ist das am Ende sogar besser als
Teams? Wie installiert man das eigentlich?
Bleibt dran, es wird überraschend.
Open Source
Das ist ja grausam.
Mein Ohr!
Wenn ihr euch für Nextcloud interessiert, seid ihr vermutlich vorsichtig mit euren Daten.
Da könnte euch Mammuth interessieren.
Die haben ihre Server nämlich in Deutschland stehen.
Für 11,90€ im Monat bekommt ihr hier Zugriff auf GPT, Cloud, Mistral, Gemini, DeepSeq,
Perplexity sowie Flux und NanoBanana für die Bildgenerierung.
Die neuesten Versionen werden sofort nach Veröffentlichung freigeschaltet.
Der Preis ist echt ziemlich heiß, wenn man bedenkt, dass alleine ChatGPT Plus über das
doppelte Monat kostet. Mit Mammuth
könnt ihr obendrein Antworten per
Reprompting vergleichen, Dokumente und Bilder
analysieren, personalisierte Projekte
erstellen oder mit der Sprach-KI
sprechen. Mammuth ist ein
europäisches Unternehmen mit strenger Datenschutz-
Policy. Wie gesagt, die Server stehen
in Deutschland. Alles im Starter-Paket
ab 11,90 Euro inklusive
Mehrwertsteuer für Privatkunden.
Was ist denn da alles drin mit 11,90 Euro?
Lass mal kurz, das ist...
Nicht, dass ich mir kaufen will, aber gerade mal
gucken. Okay, Zugang zu den besten
LLMs, das ist schon mal klar.
Okay, das ist einfach ein bisschen
schlecht aligned hier. Das ist eine Zeile
zu hoch. Da hat der Webdesigner
geschlafen.
Das ist der Umbruch hier in Mehrwertsteuer
und hier ist kein Umbruch in Mehrwertsteuer.
Ja, wenn ihr das interessant findet, schaut mal in die
Beschreibung. Da findet ihr mehr Infos
und einen Link zu Mammuts.
Vielleicht auch wipecoded.
Achso, ich wollte noch sagen, dass Heise wieder die SecIT für Security-Profis anbietet.
Und zwar vom 18. bis 19. März hier in Hannover mit redaktionell.
Erstmal ganz kurz unser Nextcloud-Versuchsaufbau.
Wir nutzen hier bei CT3003 bislang Microsoft Teams zur Kommunikation, also Chatten und Videocalls.
Google Docs für Skripte und Dropbox zum Videospuren hin und her schicken.
All das haben wir durch Nextcloud ersetzt.
Was wir nicht ersetzt haben, ist unsere E-Mail, einfach weil die von unserem Arbeitgeber Heise administriert wird.
Da kommen wir also nicht ohne weiteres ran und das können wir nicht einfach verändern.
Jetzt aber erstmal, warum ist das denn überhaupt so ein Thema?
Also zum Beispiel reden ja viele gerade vom Digital Independence Day, der von Organisationen wie dem ja sehr renommierten CCC ins Leben gerufen wurde.
Warum soll man denn überhaupt weg wollen von US-Diensten?
Ja, das ist ganz einfach. Seit dem sogenannten Cloud Act darf die US-Regierung alle US-Unternehmen, also Microsoft, Google, Apple, Dropbox und so weiter, dazu verpflichten, Kundendaten herauszugeben.
Und zwar auch dann, wenn die Server gar nicht in den USA stehen, sondern zum Beispiel in Europa.
Und solche Datenanfragen sind oft noch mit sogenannten Gag Orders verbunden.
Das heißt, Microsoft und Co. dürfen mich als Kunden gar nicht darüber informieren, dass sie gerade meine Daten herausgegeben haben.
Ja, das leuchtet vermutlich allen Menschen in Europa ein, egal wie politisch ausgerichtet man so ist, dass das ein Problem ist.
Kurze Meinung von mir, bevor es wieder auf die Technik-Ebene geht.
Mir ist völlig unklar, wie die bayerische Landesregierung unter diesen Bedingungen...
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Aber ich glaube, das liegt einfach daran, dass Microsoft in München nicht allzu weit weg ist und gute Sales-Leute wahrscheinlich am Start hatte wieder.
... den Vertrag mit Microsoft zu schließen, der fast eine Milliarde Euro schwer ist. Alle anderen Bundesländer haben sich auf den Deutschland-Stack geeinigt, bei dem Open Source zumindest priorisiert werden soll. Naja, und ich finde auch, Unternehmen sollten mal gucken, ob man sich wirklich ausschließlich auf US-Big Tech-Produkte verlassen will. So, jetzt geht es wieder ganz konkret um Nextcloud. Und zwar erstmal die Beobachtung...
da durchaus konkurrenzfähige Produkte zu erstellen.
Ich glaube, woran es bei uns scheitert, ist einfach übertriebenste Bürokratie an allen Ecken.
Das gibt sich keiner.
... von mir als Anwender, was ich jetzt in den ersten Wochen mit Nextcloud so für Erkenntnisse hatte.
Wir werden zu unserem Langzeiturteil nochmal ein eigenes Video machen.
Wir werden da noch viel mehr ins Detail gehen.
Wenn ihr sowas jetzt schon lesen wollt, empfehle ich euch diesen Artikel hier auf heise plus.
Der ist auch in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Achso, und wie man die Nextcloud aufsetzt, sowohl bei sich zu Hause als auch beim Hoster, das erklärt Lukas gleich auch noch ausführlich.
So, direkt der erste Start funktionierte wirklich erstaunlich smooth.
Lukas hatte uns allen so einen Link geschickt mit so einem Starter-Passwort.
Da klickt man drauf, gibt Passwort ein, ändert das Passwort, kann auf Wunsch einen zweiten Faktor aktivieren und dann ist das schon alles fertig.
Und wenn man da dann drin ist zum ersten Mal, sieht man die einzelnen Bestandteile hier oben, der Nextcloud. Die einzelnen Komponenten kann Lukas als Admin natürlich beliebig an- und ausschalten.
Ich meinte jetzt gar nicht in Bezug auf Open Source. Also ich meinte jetzt wirklich, dass man sagt, okay, man möchte beispielsweise Konkurrenz zu Microsoft-Produkten entwickeln. Ob das jetzt Open Source ist? Ich meine, das wäre natürlich wünschenswert oder nicht. Sei mal dahingestellt.
Und ich glaube, es ist einfach, es gibt so krass bürokratische Hürden bei jedem Scheiß hier.
Das ist doch das beste Beispiel.
Der Fahrradweg wieder.
Nordrhein, Nordmeinisch, Nord, Nord, nördlich des Main und südlich des Main Fahrradweg.
Die machen da seit 15 Jahren rum, sind jetzt bei der dritten Machbarkeitsstudie und kriegen es einfach nicht gebacken.
Zuerst mal das Dashboard mit den letzten verwendeten Dateien und halt die anstehenden Termine.
Hier gibt es Nextcloud Talk. Da kann man a. per Text kommunizieren und b. Videocalls machen.
Und hier sind die Dateien, also das was woanders OneDrive oder Dropbox heißt.
Und wenn die Dateien Office-Dokumente sind, dann kann man die natürlich auch direkt editieren, wenn man da drauf klickt.
Dahinter steckt dann standardmäßig Collabora Online. Das ist quasi die Online-Version von LibreOffice.
Ja, und hier gibt es einen eigenen Bereich für Fotos, da alle Aktivitäten, also was so passiert ist. Mail, da könnte man einen IMAP-Server verbinden. Hier dann noch Kontakte, Termine, Notizen, Aufgaben und wie ich finde sehr praktisch, Deck. Das sind so Kanban-Boards, so schön zum Hinhören.
Also das habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, das hat einen ziemlich unfertigen Eindruck gemacht, aber das ist auch schon jetzt wieder, wann hat man das zuletzt ausprobiert? Drei Jahre oder so, zwei Jahre, zwei bis drei Jahre her, da war das noch nicht so geil, aber vielleicht funktioniert das mittlerweile deutlich besser.
herrscht. Ja, und weil wir das selbst
administrieren, gibt es auch noch eine Doom-Version.
Ist ja auch sonst langweilig mit
dem ganzen Bürokram, ne? Doom
hatte Lukas hier im Nextcloud App Store
gefunden. Da gibt es noch sehr viele andere
Sachen, die man einfach so dazu installieren
kann. Was ich direkt super nice finde,
das läuft auf einer eigenen Domain.
Das heißt, wenn ihr mit eurem
Einrad-Hockey-Verein
Nextcloud so Kommunikation nutzen wollt,
dann läuft das Ding zum Beispiel auf
nextcloud.einrad-hockey-erlangen.de
und euer berufliches Nextcloud läuft dann zum Beispiel auf schraubenfabrik.de
und ich finde das durchaus ziemlich elegant, dass ihr dann unterschiedliche Nextclouds
in unterschiedlichen Browser-Tabs haben könnt.
Das stimmt, da habe ich so noch gar nicht dran gedacht, das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Das ist ja mit Teams nicht so ohne weiteres möglich.
Also wenn du Teams, das ist quasi global für die Browser-Session eingeloggt,
Du könntest unterschiedliche Browser haben, das würde funktionieren. Und theoretisch auch, könntest Inkognito-Tabs aufmachen und sowas. Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich nicht so schön dann mit Teams. Ja, das sehe ich als Vorteil.
sehe ich ein.
Bei Teams geht das nicht. Wenn ihr das im Browser
benutzt, dann müsst ihr euch dann ausloggen
und wieder einloggen mit dem jeweils
anderen Account. Ja, ich weiß, mit der
Teams Desktop App kann man
switchen, aber ich benutze halt
gern Browser, weil ich auch gerne
Linux benutze und da gibt es keinen
Teams Client. Immer noch nicht?
Es gab mal einen Teams Client für Linux.
Also den Einser Teams Client für
Linux.
Gibt es immer noch keinen.
Na dann. Ja, und jetzt zum Talk-Bereich.
Könnte Microsoft doch mal schnell Vibe coden.
Mit Leuten kommuniziert. Da fand ich direkt die Schubdizität echt gut.
Also das hat alles angenehm schnell reagiert.
Fand ich überall bei Nextcloud übrigens.
Also da ist mir nie irgendwas Lahmes aufgefallen.
Also sowohl bei der auf dem Home-Server gehosteten Version, als auch bei der im Rechenzentrum.
Ja und bei Nextcloud Talk kann man halt chatten und GIFs schicken und umfragen, was man so kennt und was man so braucht.
Und der Chat unterstützt auch YouTube-Link-Vorschauen.
Das ist so ein Spezial-Ärgernis von mir, wenn das nicht geht.
Geht da aber.
Ja, und klar, man kann auch zum Beispiel einen Doc oder einen ODT schicken im Talk.
Und da können dann alle drin rumeditieren.
Natürlich auch gleichzeitig.
Guck mal, wie schön das klappt mit unterschiedlichen Farben und Namen.
Leute, so kollaboriertes...
Gibt das das Wort? Gibt es kollaboriert?
Also so Zusammenarbeiten an einem Excel-Dokument.
Das ist so eklig.
Zum Beispiel ist es so, dass ich muss ja auf der Arbeit öfters mal in irgendwelche doofen Excel-Tabellen reingucken, weil immer noch Excel an allen Ecken verwendet wird.
Und wenn man Filter setzt, also wir haben da teilweise Excel-Tabellen, die haben was weiß ich, 8000 Zeilen oder sowas.
So, und da kann man Filter setzen, so im Header von den Excel-Dateien.
Aber dieser Filter, der da gesetzt wird,
der ist dann global für alle Leute, die da gerade kollaborieren.
Und dann siehst du die Hälfte wieder nicht.
Das ist ganz abartig.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man auf die Idee kommt,
dass das eine gute Art ist, Informationen zu sharen.
Eine geteilte Excel-Tabelle.
Das ist richtig nervig.
Es gibt aber, glaube ich, die Möglichkeit,
genau, ich weiß, es gibt die Möglichkeit,
dass man das nur für sich speichert. Das schlägt
sogar Office mittlerweile vor.
Wollen sie
diesen Filter für alle
speichern. Aber die Leute drücken halt einfach Enter.
Weil sie blöd sind.
Aber das ist so, das ist
richtig, aber nicht.
Am Cursor. Also nice.
Klar, das sieht alles etwas rudimentärer
aus als Office oder Google Docs.
Aber ich muss sagen, alle Funktionen, die
ich bislang gebraucht habe, habe ich sofort gefunden.
Die waren auch vorhanden. Also
zum Beispiel sowas wie Änderungen markieren
oder auch Notizen in das Dokument reinmachen.
Ich habe da nichts zu beanstanden gehabt.
Außer manchmal so optischen Kleinigkeiten,
dass manchmal, wenn man einen Text markieren wollte,
dass man das nicht richtig gesehen hat.
Excel als Datenbank benutzen.
Wisst ihr, es gab ja früher in Office noch Access.
Ich habe legit nie.
Also ich verstehe ja schon die Daseinsberechtigung von Office
in vielen Teilen nicht.
Aber die Daseinsberechtigung von Access, die habe ich wirklich noch nie verstanden. Also wenn einer irgendwelche Daten organisiert speichern will, dann kann er es in Excel machen. Also Excel ist ja immer die Idee der Sekretärin.
Wenn eine richtig echte Datenbank will, dann benutzt er ja meinetwegen Microsoft SQL.
Aber was ist die Daseinsberechtigung von Access?
Was genau? Also was ist der Anwendungsfall? Wann benutze ich eine Access-Datenbank?
BWL, Leute? Ich verstehe es nämlich wirklich nicht, den Sinn davon.
absolut keine Ahnung, wozu man Access braucht.
Auswertungsgedöns.
Das machen die Leute doch dann in Excel.
Wir haben Access in der Schule,
haben wir das gemacht.
Und da habe ich es auch noch nicht verstanden,
wofür man das braucht.
Access hat richtige,
relationale Datenbanken mit Form und...
Ja, aber...
Ach so, du meinst so die Kombination
aus einer echten
Datenbank mit einem halbwegs
passenden GUI dabei.
So diese Kombination.
Ja, okay.
Das war dann quasi so ein bisschen
ähm
Wie nennt man das?
So ein bisschen No-Code
bevor es No-Code hieß.
Also so eine Plattform, wo man nicht programmieren muss und programmieren kann.
Und Anwendungen erstellen, ohne programmieren zu können.
So war Access dann im Endeffekt.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alles leuchtet ein.
Zeitig, solche Sachen.
Ich habe auch so Tests gemacht.
Ich fände es übrigens mega nice, dass er seine Fernsteuerung da von seiner Aufnahme, dass das mit dem Super Nintendo Controller macht.
Einen Riesenblock Text reinpasten und sofort den Browser zumachen und hat gar keine Probleme verursacht, wurde alles zuverlässig gespeichert.
Das ist natürlich das aller ärgerlichste bei so kollaborativen Office-Plattformen, dass sie irgendwelche Sachen verschwenden.
Ist uns bislang nicht passiert.
Ja, und Videomeetings haben wir auch ziemlich intensiv getestet.
Und die Bildqualität fand ich meistens tiptop und auch meistens ruckelfrei.
Und das hat die üblichen Funktionen, die man so kennt.
Also unscharfer Hintergrund oder Hintergrund austauschen hat auch direkt so tolle Hintergrundvoreinstellungen.
Man braucht aber, wenn man das selbst hostet, wobei man braucht da eigentlich gar keinen
fetten Server.
Das ist ja alles WebRTC und WebRTC ist ja P2P.
Das geht ja gar nicht über den Server drüber.
Wie macht das Teams eigentlich, Leute?
Macht Teams Videos?
Müssen die über einen zentralen Server geschleust werden?
Oder geht das P2P?
Weil so Sachen wie Hintergrund ausblenden und blören und sowas,
das ist ja höchstwahrscheinlich kleinseitig.
Oh, who's source?
Ja gut, Teams braucht zentrale Server wegen der Aufnahmefunktion, okay, okay.
Aber, ja okay, aber nur wenn du aufnimmst, ja, also.
Es wird ja auch nicht jedes Video aufgenommen, sondern nur der Presentator, oder?
das kann man auf dem Server machen, aber da muss man
noch nicht jedes einzelne Video über den
Server schicken.
Ja, ja, das ist für einen Call. Zentrale Server
braucht alles. Die Frage ist, ob
jeder Videostream in Teams
auch über den zentralen Server
laufen muss. Ich denke mal nicht. Ich denke,
dass sie da auch WebRTC machen, oder?
Weil ansonsten wäre das ja ultra
viel
Traffic.
Bilder hier so geil.
Oh, Raumschiff. Also bis ungefähr
vier bis fünf Leute geht das alles
problemlos, auch auf der selbst gehosteten
Nextcloud. Aber ab dann braucht
man so ein sogenanntes High
Performance Backend. Das war
bei unserer Hetzner-Installation direkt mit drin.
Musste man nicht extra installieren.
Und das Ding tut, was es soll. Also da ging
das auch mit mehr Leuten im Call.
Aber so Aussagen zur generellen Stabilität der Videocalls im Vergleich zu Microsoft Teams, das finde ich wirklich noch schwierig.
Dafür würde ich gerne noch deutlich mehr Meeting-Erfahrung sammeln.
Machen wir ja alles noch und da gibt es dann auch so ein Langzeit-Testvideo.
Cool finde ich auf jeden Fall, dass ich allen Leuten, also auch extern, einfach einen eigenen Link mit unserer Domain schicken kann.
Und dann klicken die das an und dann kann man sofort Videocallen.
Das finde ich viel souveräner, als so einen schnöden Microsoft- oder Zoom-Link zu verschicken.
Ja, das gleiche gilt auch für die Dateiverwaltung.
Das ist ja die klassische ursprüngliche Funktion von Nextcloud.
Da kann ich einfach externen Leuten einen Link schicken und dann können die Leute da Dateien hochladen ohne Anmeldung.
Also auch so riesig große 4K-Videodateien, das ist tatsächlich was, was wir häufig brauchen,
dass man sowas durch die Gegend schicken will, also auch von externen Leuten.
Wenn man das halt selbst hostet, ist die Größe nur durch die angeschlossenen Datenträger begrenzt.
Also man kann da riesige Dateien drauf speichern und rumschicken.
Ich habe den Nextcloud Client auf meinem Handy installiert und da eingestellt,
dass alle Fotos und Videos direkt im Hintergrund hochgeladen werden sollen, also quasi als Backup.
Ja, und wenn ich meinen Kollegen für ein CT3003 Video einen Schnipsel geben will, gebe ich den einfach frei.
Das ist ja dann alles schon in die Nextcloud hochgeladen.
Funktionierte in meinen Tests einwandfrei.
Für Desktops gibt es auch einen Client, der zumindest...
Also, wo ich früher mal Probleme hatte, ist mit dem ILSYNC zwischen zwei Rechnern.
Da hatte ich viele kleine Textdateien und da ist sich das manchmal nicht mehr hergekommen.
Aber das ist auch schon Jahre her, also vielleicht ist es mittlerweile viel besser.
bei meinen Tests auch problemlos funktioniert hat.
Und man kann hier, das fand ich super,
auch unterschiedliche Accounts parallel verwenden.
Hier, guck mal.
Dieser Ordner hier bei mir auf der SSD
ist mit der lokal gehosteten Nextcloud-Instanz synchronisiert.
Dieser mit der im Rechenzentrum.
Nice.
Also von mir erst mal nichts zu meckern.
Aber wie gesagt, wir nutzen das weiter
und machen noch einen Langzeittest.
So, jetzt aber zu Lukas und wie man das Ganze installiert.
Ja gut, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
mein Nextcloud installiert.
Achso, so lang geht das
nur dann.
Danke Lukas. Nextcloud ist
auf jeden Fall eine Alternative zu den
Produkten der US-Big Tech
Unternehmen. Diese Aussage traue ich mir auch
schon vor unserem Langzeittest zu.
Ein Unterschied ist doch,
wobei ich mir da nicht sicher bin, ob das wirklich stimmt,
man muss halt viel selbst administrieren.
Bei Teams
und Office weniger.
Wobei ich da halt auch denke,
Da ist vielleicht nicht so viel Administration um das Hosting dabei bei Teams und bei Office.
Aber konfigurieren und administrieren musst du da trotzdem viel.
Also wahrscheinlich nimmt sich das gar nicht mal so großartig was.
Das User Interface ist jetzt nicht das allerschönste, das ich jemals gesehen habe.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe es mir viel schlimmer vorgestellt.
Ich finde das alles ganz angenehm reduziert.
Und ich war auch echt positiv von der Schwubbizität überrascht.
Das lief alles ziemlich geschmeidig.
Und grobe Bugs sind mir in den ersten Wochen auch nicht untergekommen, von den erwähnten Kleinigkeiten mal abgesehen, also dass einmal die Textmarkierungen in der Online-Textverarbeitung nicht angezeigt wurden zum Beispiel. Aber für mich, und das war eigentlich die größte Erkenntnis, fühlte sich das Experiment nicht so an, als müsste ich irgendwie für unsere digitale Souveränität Opfer bringen oder so, sondern ich habe gerne mit Nextcloud gearbeitet. Also bislang, mal sehen, ob das so bleibt. Ja, wie seht ihr das?
Eine Sache, die ich auch bei Nextcloud ein bisschen blöd finde, da kann Nextcloud aber nichts dafür, für Kontakte und Kalender.
Das ist ja CalDAV und CardDAV, immer noch, gehe ich mal von aus.
Dafür gibt es einfach keine gescheiten Clients so richtig.
Unter iOS geht es mit Trick 17, das halbwegs zu integrieren.
Unter Windows gar nicht richtig.
unter Linux, da kannst du
Thunderbird verwenden oder so.
Das kannst du in der Windows auch verwenden.
Aber wenn du wirklich deine
Notizen,
Kalender und sowas
darüber machen willst, da gibt es sehr wenig
gescheite Clients.
Auf Android
brauchst du irgendwie
mit Tasker kannst du dann
synken im Hintergrund und sowas.
Ja.
Das ist alles nicht so schön.
Da haben halt so Sachen wie Google Kalender
einen riesen Vorteil, ich benutze keinen Google Kalender,
ich sag's nur, ne, Vorteil,
der Kram, der tut halt überall gleich,
auf allen Plattformen.
So.
Also, die finden
Nextcloud ganz nice. Na gut, ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube ich werde es mir in nächster Zeit nicht angucken.
Ich habe da keinen
Anwendungsfall aktuell für.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier zu gucken?
Mein neues Lieblings-Linux
Pop!OS ausprobiert.
Ich weiß
nicht. Pop!OS.
Wir können uns das mal angucken. Wenn wir eh schon
KCT 3003 gucken.
Pop!OS. Genau, ich habe doch
Und letztens gab es doch ein Video von Linus Tech Tips, der hat doch auch PopOS verwendet.
Und sie haben sich dabei wieder ein bisschen...
...Bepega angestellt.
Na komm, gucken wir mal. Guck mal, es geht ja nicht lang, 13 Minuten.
Guck mal hier, das bin ich auf meiner ewig währenden Mission, das perfekte Betriebssystem für mich zu finden.
Und...
War mal ein Tick lauter.
Ich glaube, wir haben einen ganz heißen Kandidaten am Start.
Diese Linux-Distribution läuft out of the box wirklich ultra schnell.
Also wirklich, snappier geht's.
Ist das Problem bei Pop!OS nicht,
dass Pop!OS mittlerweile standardmäßig mit Cosmic Desktop läuft
und Cosmic Desktop ist quasi noch gar nicht richtig fertig?
Ja, genau, genau, genau das, genau das.
Das habe ich auch so im Hintergrund.
Dass Cosmic doch noch gar nicht so richtig fertig ist.
Ich glaube, da gibt es jetzt zwar eine 1.0-Version von,
aber das ist immer noch nicht so richtig fertig.
Bin mal gespannt.
Und ist vor allem auf Gaming ausgelegt,
was auch butterweich läuft.
Außerdem sieht das Teil auch noch total schick aus.
Aber Gaming ist ja wahrscheinlich
bei allen Linux-Restaurationen irgendwie gleich.
Wenn man die passenden Sachen installiert.
Wenn ich das nicht unbedingt wollte.
Das Ding nennt sich PopOS und ist aktuell
ein ganz heißes Teil auf dem Distro-Markt.
Und die Frage ist, ist es das?
Ist es das perfekte Betriebssystem oder müssen wir
die Blase poppen lassen.
In diesem Video klären wir genau diese Frage
und schauen uns mal an, wie sich der Cosmic Desktop von Pop!OS so anfühlt.
Ja, so heißt die auch unabhängig von Pop!OS gerade ziemlich gehypte Desktop-Umgebung.
Und ich kann jetzt schon mal sagen, in Cosmic sind Ideen verbaut,
die ich so noch auf keinem anderen Desktop gesehen habe.
Bleibt dran.
Also was mir persönlich überhaupt nicht gefällt,
ist diese Farbgebung mit dem grünen Zeug hier.
Vielleicht hat er das auch eingestellt, weil er das Grün mag, aber mir gefällt das überhaupt nicht.
Und noch auf keinem anderen Desktop gesehen habe. Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Ja, und es gibt auch einen nativen Linux-Client für NordVPN, die sponsern dieses Video.
NordVPN, ein neues Betriebssystem, hat den Chat betreten.
Naja, neu im Sinne von ich will was Neues ausprobieren und hab vielleicht auch mein Cache OS neulich ein bisschen kaputt gespielt.
Hoppla.
Also Pop OS gibt es schon seit einer Weile, aber ich finde man hört in letzter Zeit immer öfter, dass Leute das ausprobieren.
Also zumindest in meiner Bubble.
Zum Beispiel auch Linus von den gleichnamigen Tech Tips.
Das Ding wird vom US-amerikanischen Computerhersteller System76 entwickelt.
Die verkaufen Laptops und Desktop-Rechner, die, wer hätt's gedacht, standardmäßig mit Pop OS oder Ubuntu auskaufen.
Zum Glück ist es nicht System 6.7, sonst hören sie ja alle durchdrehen wieder.
Ja, aber auch wenn das von einem kommerziellen Entwickler kommt, ist Pop!OS komplett Open Source und kostenlos.
Und Pop!OS ist ein Ubuntu-Derivat und vor allem auf Gaming ausgelegt.
Beim Download kann man jeweils eine Version für AMD, Nvidia oder Intel-GPUs runterladen.
Da sind dann jeweils die passenden Treiber schon vorinstalliert.
Also in meinem Fall die ISO für Nvidia-Karten runterladen, auf einen USB-Stick packen und installieren.
Falls ihr die Installation von Minus...
Das ist schon viel zu lang. Hast du recht, das kann nicht mehr angesagt sein.
Was ist denn jetzt angesagt?
Also ich meine, wir hatten 6.9, 6.7, das heißt jetzt vollkommener 6.8.
Im Detail sehen wollt, habe ich euch einen Link in die Beschreibung gepackt, wo wir das schon mal erklärt hatten.
Beim ersten Start von Pop!OS ist mir direkt erstmal aufgefallen, wie schnell das läuft und wie schick das Ganze auch noch dabei aussieht.
Die Optik bzw. die Bedienung ist eh für mich das größte Highlight an Pop! OS, aber da komme ich später noch zu.
Ja, also das Ding ist wirklich schnell und alles fühlt sich wirklich super snappy an.
Bisher hatte ich ja immer Cache OS laufen und das ist auch schon super schwupsig, aber wenn ich jetzt wählen müsste, dann würde ich sagen, dass sich Pop! OS nochmal einen kleinen Schnuff knackiger anfühlt.
Alleine hier die Fenster im Tiling-Modus rumzuschieben oder die Workspaces zu wechseln, fühlt sich super schnell an.
Aber das ist vielleicht auch diese Euphorie, wenn man ein neues Betriebssystem ausprobiert.
Also CacheOS ist auch schon sehr schnell.
Und zu Gaming kommen wir gleich auch noch.
Das läuft nämlich auch brutal weich.
Also alle normalen Programme, die ich installiert hatte, starten hier wirklich auf der Stelle.
Und auch die Installation von Software geht super schnell.
Denn bei Pop!OS ist der Cosmic Store vorinstalliert.
Das ist ein grafischer App Store mit Suchfunktionen, Kategorien, Bildern, Beschreibungen und so weiter.
Also alles, was man...
Das hat ja mittlerweile gefühlt jeder.
Wobei, ich mache das ja nie über das GUI.
Wie sieht denn das bei CacheOS eigentlich aus?
Wie installiert man denn da offiziell was?
Software?
Ne, äh, Package?
CacheOS Package Manager.
Okay, das sieht hässlich aus.
Das gebe ich zu.
Das sieht hässlich aus.
Wobbly Windows ist das Wichtigste.
Okay, das sieht wirklich nicht so schön aus,
wie der andere Store.
Oder vielleicht soll ich mal nach Store suchen?
Ne.
Octopie.
Ist Octopie...
Ähm...
Octopie ist doch ne Raspberry Pi Distribution
für 3D Drucker.
Naja, so viel besser finde ich das jetzt auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Da finde ich den anderen Store schon schöner.
Aber mich stört das nicht.
Also, ich installiere das hier eh über CLI.
Wie stellt man Wobbly Windows ein?
Hier, Desktop Effects.
Effects.
Musst du hin.
Da, Desktop Effects.
Und dann gehst du hier runter, runter, runter, runter.
Und unter Appearance.
Wobbly Windows.
Ohne Wobbly Windows
Und jetzt will ich beste mit Wobbly Windows
Und auch viel besser
Man kann glaube ich sogar die Wobbliness einstellen
Hier Wobbliness
Wobbliness volle Pulle
Und jetzt wobbelt es wie sonst was
Guck mal hier
Es hört gar nicht mehr auf zu wobbeln
Guck mal sobald ich den Mauszeiger loslasse
Wobbelt es immer noch
Massive Wobbly.
Und mal gleich fliegt es weg.
So ich mach es mal wieder ein bisschen runter.
Okay weiter.
So braucht.
Wenn ich hier etwas installiere dauert das nur wenige Sekunden und das Programm ist sofort
ready.
Hier beispielsweise Discord.
Ich klicke da drauf, der installiert das in ungefähr zwei Sekunden und ich kann es sofort starten.
Schon nice.
Der Cosmic Store ist in Rust geschrieben und läuft mit wenig Speicher.
Blazingly fast.
Zum Vergleich, die andere populäre App.
Desktop-Würfel habe ich auch, aber die benutze ich nicht.
Ich finde Desktop-Würfel ist einfach nur Spielerei.
Die Verwaltung KDE Discover hat schon deutlich mehr Funktionen, ist aber definitiv schwerfälliger.
Cosmic kann aber auch wie Discover zwischen Flatpak und Systempaketen umschalten.
Ganz kurz nochmal der Unterschied.
Flatpacks bringen alle Abhängigkeiten selbst mit und laufen abgeschottet in einer Sandbox.
Können also euer System nicht zerschießen. Systempakete sind tiefer ins Linux-System
integriert, teilen sich Bibliotheken mit anderen Programmen, verbrauchen dadurch auch weniger
Speicherplatz, aber können halt im schlimmsten Fall Probleme verursachen. Apropos Systempakete,
Pop!OS basiert auf Ubuntu und hier ist standardmäßig der Paketmanager apt installiert.
Den musste ich aber für meine Programme kein einziges Mal mit der Kommandozeile benutzen.
Alles, was ich installieren wollte, habe ich installiert.
Es gibt ja unter Debian drei Varianten.
Du hast das ganz Alte, das ist apt-get.
Dann hast du aptitude, das ist so das Mittelalter.
Und seit ein paar Jahren hast du apt.
Und apt ist auch, finde ich, mit Abstand am einfachsten und besten zu benutzen.
Vor als Flatpak gefunden.
Und während Ubuntu weiterhin das viel kritisierte Snap-Paketsystem verwendet,
ist bei Pop!OS Snap nicht mal vorinstalliert.
Auch ein komplettes System-Update geht über den Cosmic Store einfach unter Aktualisierungen und da kann man alles...
Stimmt, dpkg hast du noch unten drunter, ja.
Aber das benutzt ja niemand von Hand.
Hoffe ich.
Updaten.
Also das ist so ähnlich wie bei Linux Mint, da läuft ja auch fast alles über die grafische Oberfläche.
Bei CacheOS, was ja auf Arch basiert, braucht man schon irgendwie häufiger mal die Kommandozeile.
Arch, by the way.
Doch, eine Kleinigkeit habe ich dann doch per Kommandozeile installiert, und zwar...
NeoFetch.
Ja, muss.
Ohne...
Wobei, Neo Fetch ist ja outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Fast Fetch ist ja das Angesagte mittlerweile.
Das ist diese Systemanzeige mit passenden ASCII-Art vom Distro-Logo,
die man beim Öffnen vom Terminal bekommt.
Ich hab das mittlerweile so gehandhabt, guck mal.
Mein Neo Fetch ist ein Alias auf Fast Fetch.
Da kann ich tippen, was ich will.
Braucht man nicht DPKG für Chrome-Depp?
Nee, brauchst du nicht.
Du kannst einfach sagen, apt install und dann fahrt zum Debian Packages.
Früher musstest du noch machen, apt get local install.
Oder war das yum?
Yum local install.
Aber mittlerweile kannst du einfach sagen, apt install.slash.plup.deb.
Ich verwende in Skripten auch apt.
Ich weiß, dass es immer eine Fehlermeldung gibt.
Keine Fehlermeldung, eine Warning-Meldung.
App has no stable
interface oder irgendwas. Ich verwende überall
App nur noch bei Debian.
So kannst du auch
Debian-Packages installieren.
Ich jetzt nicht, weil ich bin nicht
auf dem Debian. Aber ich kann es
dir zeigen.
Glaub mir, trust me, Chat.
Das funzt.
Die ist standardmäßig bei Pop!OS nicht
vorinstalliert und im Store habe ich das auch
nicht gefunden. Witzigerweise wird das Pop-OS-Logo mit 7 und 6 angezeigt, passend zum Entwickler
System76. Also das hat nichts mit dem 677... Oh nein, hör mir auf, please! Und ja, ich
weiß, NeoFetch ist mittlerweile eigentlich veraltet und von FastFetch abgelöst. FastFetch
hat bei mir aber so komische Farben beim Logo angezeigt, das hat mich genervt und ich hatte
keinen Bock da irgendwie groß rumzufummeln, deswegen habe ich jetzt einfach NeoFetch verwendet.
Naja, ist auch eh alles komplett unnötig, sonst lief wirklich alles einfach über den
Ja, und der Store ist Teil vom Cosmic Desktop, das Desktop-Environment von Pop!OS.
Nochmal als Reminder, ein Desktop-Environment, beziehungsweise eine Desktop-Umgebung,
ist eine Sammlung an Programmen, die die komplette Benutzeroberfläche vom Betriebssystem bilden.
Also sowas wie Fenstermanagement, Startmenü und so weiter.
Und das ist auch das, was den kompletten Look and Feel bei der Bedienung am Ende ausmacht.
Ja, ich muss sagen, dass mir das bei Pop!OS richtig, richtig gut gefällt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was Cosmic so viel nicer machen soll als KDE.
Also ihr wisst ja, ich habe jahrelang i3 verwendet.
Das ist ein Tiling Window Manager.
Und jetzt, seitdem ich hier bei CacheOS auf dem Mini-PC gelandet bin,
habe ich mir KDE konfiguriert mit Shortcuts,
wie ich sie vom Tiling Window Manager kenne.
Also ich habe exakt die gleichen Shortcuts.
Ich habe Ctrl-D zum Anwendungsstarten,
Control-P, oh, hab ich noch nicht gemappt,
ähm,
Enter, äh, Terminal starten,
ähm, und solche Geschichten, ja,
oder zwischen den Desktops switchen und
verschieben und alles, aber ich wär im Prinzip genauso,
und das lässt sich,
ehrlich gesagt, zu 90%
genauso bedienen, wie
mein Tiling-Window-Manager, ich brauch
das andere gar nicht mehr, und ich muss
sagen, so das Gesamtpaket von KDE
gefällt mir echt gut,
also
Ich sehe jetzt aktuell keinen Grund,
irgend großartig was anderes zu verwenden.
Warum heißt das Teil eigentlich PopOS?
Laut System76-CEO Carl Ritchell
steht das Pop für die knalligen Farben
und der Unterstrich kommt vom System76-Tool.
No, mag ich gar nicht.
Wo hier unter der 6 auch so ein Strich ist.
Na gut, der Unterstrich ist aber vielleicht auch einfach wichtig,
dass die Leute das Ding nicht immer Popos aussprechen.
So zumindest unsere Theorie.
Das Pop zieht sich auch durch andere Produkte von System76, wie beispielsweise deren USB-Flash-Tool Popsicle.
Anyways, jetzt einmal zum Look and Feel von Popos, beziehungsweise vom Cosmic Desktop.
Der Cosmic Desktop ist ein eigens von System76 entwickeltes Desktop-Environment, was hier und da Ähnlichkeiten mitgenommen hat.
Und ich finde, das fühlt sich richtig frisch an.
Hier zum Beispiel der Login-Screen, den finde ich richtig schick, oder?
Ich kann, ich mag dieses Grün einfach nicht.
Ich weiß, der hat sein CacheOS auch irgendwie so eingestellt.
Er mag anscheinend diese Kombination aus grüner Schrift.
Und ich finde, das sieht irgendwie...
Also mein Fall ist es nicht.
Ansonsten hat man hier oben so eine Menu-Bar und hier unten ein Dock.
Hier beim Dock gibt es aber eine Kleinigkeit, die mich stört.
Wenn man ein Fenster groß macht, dann ziehen sich die Kanten des Docks hier so automatisch bis an die Ränder.
Und smooth sieht das irgendwie nicht aus.
Ja, das finde ich auch nicht schön.
In der Einstellung kann man das Ding aber mit diesem Schalter hier auch dauerhaft bis an den Rand ziehen.
Das wirkt dann mit den Fenstern alles irgendwie deutlich stimmiger.
Besonders wenn ich so Systemfenster hier groß mache, dann geht das hier so nahtlos über.
Das finde ich schon ganz schick.
Die Menüleiste hier oben sieht so ähnlich aus wie bei GNOME.
Also mit der Uhrzeit in der Mitte und diesen Widgets hier rechts.
Hier links sind aber noch zwei Shortcuts.
Einmal für Applications und einmal für...
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich finde es mittlerweile eigentlich so am besten.
Ich brauche keine zwei Leisten mehr oder sonst was.
Einfach eine Leiste hier oben und fertig.
Und ich habe ja auch beim Terminal und sowas, ich habe ja noch nicht mal mehr irgendwelche Fensterränder oder so.
Einfach nur, dass Fullscreen gut ist.
Im Applications-Menü sind Apps aufgelistet und out of the box sind wirklich nur ganz wenige Programme vorinstalliert.
Was ich persönlich ja richtig nice finde, so ist alles nämlich richtig schön clean, wenn man das Ding frisch installiert.
Es gibt ja auch andere Betriebssysteme, die nach einer frischen Installation schon vollgestopft sind mit Loadware.
Also ich finde auch, KDE ist ziemlich aus einem Guss.
Und was ich halt mag bei KDE, ist, dass du viel customizen kannst.
Das war schon immer so bei KDE.
Und ich habe mir das Ding quasi fast wie einen Tiling-Window-Manager customised.
Das musst du auch erstmal machen können.
Das ist Default, ich glaube, das ist Default Cache-OS.
Ich sehe meinen Hintergrund so gut wie gar nicht.
Oh hier.
Ich glaube das ist Default Cache EOS.
Stimmt. Chat.
Das habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Chatke.
Die Paper Backgrounds.
Ja Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das geht ja nicht.
Okay.
Die Pepo-Backgrounds
hab ich ja gar nicht drin.
Ähm, da sind wir jetzt wieder dabei.
Kann man unter KDE
irgendwie per CLI
Backgrounds setzen?
Weil das Ding ist,
Wenn ich jetzt hier hingehe und sage Desktop und Wallpaper, ich will ja unterschiedliche Hintergründe je nach Uhrzeit haben.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier hingehe, sagen wir, keine Ahnung, Home, Repos, White Paper Happy Images.
So, ne, jetzt habe ich die hier drinnen
Okay, aber ich will die ja automatisch
durchswitchen, je nach Uhrzeit
Okay, da brauche ich irgendeinen Discard.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken.
KDE set background from CLI.
How to set wallpaper background command line.
Plasma apply, was?
Plasma apply wallpaper image.
Ah, easy.
ok gut ok dann ist sie dann brauche ich einfach nur ein skript heißt
zement effekt wir nehmen hier mal dieses zbg und anstatt fee
was auch immer ich hier komisches gebastelt habe
okay das brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr
Äh, was?
If test find...
Alter, was zum...
Was hab ich denn hier für komische Dinger gebastelt?
Achso, Timeout, sonst was.
Ich will kein...
Ich will kein, ähm...
Was mach ich denn hier in diesem Skript überhaupt für komische Dinger?
Achso, ich guck, ob die Desktop-Datei älter ist als...
ja gut ist das das müssen wir anders machen wir machen jetzt einfach hier war
zum testen apply moment mal
hier hier kommt das random
hier ist hier immer hier kommt das random file
ja also jetzt was
Plasma
Apply
Wallpaper Image
Dollar File
Habe ich das jetzt richtig gemacht?
Okay, schauen wir mal.
ZBG
Scheint zu funktionieren, Leute.
Der Pepo ist am Start.
Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass das Bild alle paar Sekunden wechselt im Hintergrund.
Weil ich...
Wobei, das können wir doch easy fixen, oder?
Das können wir doch easy fixen.
Wir machen hier einfach...
Ja, wir machen hier einfach einen Sleep, oder?
Irgendwie Sleep.
600.
Und jetzt, bam.
Ja.
Jetzt wird das nur noch alle 10 Minuten gesetzt.
Ja, aber
der Sleep unten, der soll da bleiben.
Das muss ich eh noch anders machen,
weil ansonsten switcht der nicht
Punkt 17 Uhr und sowas.
Zumindest haben wir jetzt erstmal Pepo-Hintergründe.
Pippo 6-7, oh ne, bloß nicht
Zumindest habe ich jetzt erstmal wieder meine schönen
Pippo-Backgrounds, dann bin ich
erstmal zufrieden damit
Windows
Installationen schon vollgestopft sind
mit Bloatware
Windows
Was auch noch ganz nice ist
man kann sich hier unten im App-Fenster
Ordner anlegen und so Software
so ein bisschen sortieren
Hier neben den Applications kann man
die Workspaces öffnen. Da kann man
dann Fenster reinziehen, die Spaces hin und her
wechseln und rumschieben und so weiter.
Das funktioniert alles wirklich sehr intuitiv
und super snappy. Aber, dieses
Snappiness kommt auch daher, dass es
wirklich so gut wie gar keine Animationen
gibt. Dadurch fühlt sich zwar alles super schnell
an, aber auch etwas weniger smooth
beziehungsweise sogar auch so ein bisschen
ruckelig. Ich mag das eigentlich,
wenn es wenig Animationen gibt.
Deswegen, ich habe ja auch diese Desktop-Switch-Dinger und so
ausgeschaltet. Ich will das, sobald
ich Knopf drücke, soll instant was
passieren
ich wie ich finde es gibt ja einige die stellen immer alle animationen bei ihren
desktops aus weil die das so lieber mögen also das ist geschmackssache aber
ich persönlich bin schon fan davon wenn dinge animiert sind ich nicht ein
bisschen an anderen stellen gibt es dann schon animationen beispielsweise wenn man
hier zwischen den workspace ist hin und her wechselt ganz praktisch wenn man
Wenn man hier unten auf eine App klickt, die in einem anderen Workspace geöffnet ist, dann
switcht er automatisch zu dem richtigen Space.
Und das sieht auch alles smooth und nice aus.
Und es sind auch weitere Desktop-Animationen laut Roadmap von System76 auf jeden Fall in
Planung.
Ansonsten funktioniert das Hin- und Herwechseln zwischen Workspaces wirklich super und wenn
man Apps beendet und die Spaces dann leer sind, schließen die sich auch automatisch.
Also funktioniert alles sehr gut.
Wenn man die Super-Taste drückt, also Windows oder Option, dann öffnet sich hier so ein
Launcher für Apps.
Also Super drücken, beispielsweise Firefox eingeben und starten.
Das ist so ähnlich wie bei Gnome oder Spotlight von macOS oder so.
Und genau wie bei Spotlight hat der auch ein paar kleine Zusatzfunktionen.
Beispielsweise kann man da direkt eine Rechnung eintippen und man bekommt direkt hier in der Suche dann das Ergebnis ausgespuckt.
Wenn man Find vor einer Suchanfrage eintippt, dann sucht der Launcher direkt nach allen Dateien und nicht nur nach den Apps.
Und wenn man direkt Google davor schreibt, dann öffnet sich ein Tab im Browser mit der Google-Suche.
Schon alles ganz praktisch.
Und die eine Sache, die ich wirklich ganz besonders cool finde am Cosmic Desktop, ist diese Schaltfläche hier oben.
Da kann man nämlich spontan zwischen Tiling und schwebenden Windows hin und her wechseln.
Falls ihr nicht wisst, was das ist.
Okay, das finde ich ganz nice.
Wobei ich da sagen muss, eigentlich will ich entweder oder.
Aber es ist trotzdem ganz gut.
Ja, das ist ganz nice.
Ich meine, ich habe ja mein KDE mir mehr oder weniger hier auch so eingerichtet, von Shortcuts her, wie mein alter i3.
Schwebendes Window Management ist das, was man von Windows und macOS kennt.
Also wenn sich die Fenster so ganz normal überlappen können.
Tiling Windows ordnen sich automatisch auf dem Desktop fest an.
Also man kann die verschieben, größer und kleiner ziehen und so weiter.
Aber die hängen halt immer im Vordergrund an irgendeiner Stelle im Bild.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier oben draufklicke und auf Tiling wechsle, dann ordnen sich alle Fenster auf dem Bild an.
Also man kann hier alles fröhlich hin und her schieben und ja, ihr seht, man braucht auf jeden Fall einen kleinen Moment Übung damit, aber dann funktioniert das erstaunlich intuitiv.
Also ich finde das jetzt nicht unbedingt weniger fummelig, als mit dieser Fenster-Snap-Funktion bei Windows rumzuhantieren.
Wenn man sich richtig doll hacker-mäßig cool fühlen will, könnte man sich dann auch noch die ganzen Hotkeys aneignen und komplett nur noch mit der Tastatur arbeiten.
Dafür bin ich aber leider zu schlecht und aufzufauen.
Also ich hab's ja so hier eingerichtet wie unter I3, also sprich hier, Windows-Taste 1, 2, 3, 4 schaltet die Desktops durch, dann Ctrl-D startet Programme, Windows-Shift-Zahl schiebt es auf den jeweiligen Desktop.
äh
F macht Fullscreen, nicht Fullscreen
das ist mehr oder weniger
das meiste, was man braucht
das einzige, was ich noch nicht belegt habe, ist P
P soll bei mir eigentlich
ähm
das Clipboard
Control
X
X, ne
Moment, wie macht man jetzt hier?
Ah,
Meta V, okay.
Ich will
P.
Ja, ja, hier will ich nicht.
Ja, genau, das will ich haben.
Ich habe P für Paste.
Deswegen habe ich das auf Windows-Taste P.
Ich denke immer an Paste, wenn ich mein Clipboard verwenden will.
Aber ein Hotkey ist echt ziemlich praktisch und zwar Super-Taste plus G.
Damit kann man nämlich ein einzelnes Fenster aus dem Tiling-Windows-Desktop befreien, wenn man das mal braucht.
Also es gibt Tiling und schwebendes Window Management und man kann da halt zwischendrin her wechseln.
Das coole ist, man kann das nicht nur allgemein für den ganzen Desktop hin und her switchen, sondern das unabhängig für den Bildschirm und die Workspaces jeweils einzeln einstellen.
Das heißt, ich kann hier auf meinem linken Bildschirm Spotify, Notion und Signal irgendwie fest im Bild hängen haben, während auf meinem Hauptbildschirm alles weiter schwebt.
Die Idee, dass man das einfach die ganze Zeit hin und her switchen kann, finde ich wirklich richtig super und habe ich bisher auch noch bei keinem anderen Desktop-Environment in der Form gesehen.
Falls es das woanders gibt, dann schreibt es mal gerne in die Kommentare, ich wusste es nicht.
Und unabhängig von dem Tiling-Window-Management, man kann auch wie bei Windows die Sachen hier so an die Seiten snatten.
Also das geht auch und funktioniert auch gut.
Falls man noch ein bisschen am Desktop umbasteln will, gibt es auch noch ein paar Anpassungsmöglichkeiten in den Einstellungen.
Da kann man dann beispielsweise die Farben von Desktop...
Der mag das einfach, dass das grün ist.
Stop frei.
Mir gefällt das überhaupt nicht.
Wählen, Light oder Dark Mode auswählen, den Stil von Teilflächen jeweils runder oder eckiger anstellen.
Also erst einmal Dark Mode und dann vielleicht blau oder so.
Dann musst du vom Fenster Highlight anpassen.
Orange.
Das ist schon okay, aber richtig doll viel kann man jetzt in den Systemeinstellungen nicht anpassen.
Obwohl das hier ja ein ganz eigenes Desktop-Environment ist, gab es im Store trotzdem etwas, das sich Tweaks nennt, wie Gnome Tweaks.
Ich habe das mal runtergeladen, da kann man dann auch noch Sachen einstellen, wie die Farben oder Dinge am Dock und so weiter.
Ob man das benutzen sollte, weiß ich nicht.
Ich fand es trotzdem lustig, dass es das gibt.
Also ja, das ist halt Linux und im Zweifel kann man alles irgendwie verändern, wenn man das will.
Dazu hatten wir auch schon mal ein eigenes Video gemacht.
Gerne mal auschecken.
Okay, okay, alles schön und gut, aber was ist mit Gaming?
Läuft das genauso nice wie bei CacheOS?
Na klar läuft es genauso.
Letztendlich unter der Haube benutzen die alle das Gleiche.
Ganz simpel?
Ja, läuft es.
Ähnlich wie bei Cache sind passende GPU-Treiber direkt vorinstalliert.
Also da muss man nicht selbst runterladen.
Besten AMD.
Steam kann man easy über den Cosmic Store installieren.
Und alle Spiele, die ich ausprobiert hatte, liefen bei mir ähnlich gut wie auf meinem Windows 11.
Also sowas wie Ark Raiders, Cyberpunk 2077, Path of Exile 2 und auch Nicht-Steam-Spiele wie World of Warcraft.
Für letzteres muss man dann den Battle.net-Launcher bei Steam als Nicht-Steam-Spiel einbinden.
Ach, läuft das mittlerweile gescheit unter Linux, ja?
Auch über Proton.
Ist ein bisschen fummelig, aber das ist ein allgemeines Linux-Gaming-Problem und hat jetzt nichts mit Pop!OS zu tun.
Also vielleicht habt ihr gemerkt, ich bin wirklich großer Fan von Pop!OS und werde das auf jeden Fall in nächster Zeit als mein Hauptbetriebssystem verwenden.
Dadurch, dass man fast nie mit der Kommandozeile rumhantieren muss, eignet sich das Teil auch wirklich super als Einsteiger-Linux.
Gaming funktioniert einwandfrei und die Bedienung macht mir sehr viel Spaß.
Schreibt gerne mal in die Kommentare, was aktuell euer Lieblings-Linux ist und wie ihr Pop!OS so findet, falls ihr es schon ausprobiert habt.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
Haben wir nicht sogar mal Pop!OS ausprobiert vor 5 Jahren oder so?
Irgendwie kommt mir das...
Warte mal.
Streamtitel.
Pop.
Okay.
Vor vier Jahren.
Wo ist...
Okay.
Hat mir PopOS überhaupt nicht gefallen.
PopOS haben wir uns auch angeguckt,
habe ich da mal gesagt.
Okay, aber anscheinend gibt es den Stream nicht mehr.
Okay.
Naja gut, anscheinend nicht.
Aber ich bilde mir auch ein, wir haben uns das schon mal angeguckt.
Ja, es ist eh kein Unterschied, großartig.
Es benutzt unter der Haube ja alles das gleiche.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Man kann auch unter Ubuntu ganz normal spielen mittlerweile.
Oh ne.
Techno Tim.
MonkaS.
Hatten wir das Video nicht schon?
Hatten wir das nicht schon?
Wir haben das glaube ich nie fertig geguckt.
Aber das
PopOS hast du im Dezember 2019
ausprobiert.
Woher weißt du das?
48-Port-Switch.
Ah, da hab ich jetzt aber auch gar keinen Bock drauf, weil die Dinger bei TechnoTim ist halt so, der hat eigentlich nur diese ganze Sache, um sich selbst zu verwalten, da läuft nichts Gescheites drauf.
Ja genau, also bei ihm geht es eindeutig ums haben und nicht ums machen.
Eindeutig.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch so?
Seven AI Tools you need to know right now.
Okay.
Ne, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Aber ansonsten noch.
Guck mal hier, das ist mein Samsung Smart TV und der treibt mich komplett.
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
What? Geht drei Wochen.
Das brauchen wir auch nicht.
How I set up Windows for minimal bloat.
Ganz einfach. Am besten kein Windows verwenden.
Gibt es was Neues von Level Cap?
Boah, keine Ahnung. Level Cap habe ich ja schon ewig nicht mehr geguckt.
Wie hieß der nochmal dieser Channel, der immer so Battlefield Best-Ofs gebracht hat?
Mal gucken, ob der noch irgendwie was...
AkaArt, genau.
Okay.
Nein, der hat seit vier Jahren nichts mehr hochgeladen.
Seit Battlefield 2042 gesackt hat.
Okay.
Kann man nachfühlen.
Aha.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass Windows 11...
Was?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Das können wir uns dann angucken.
Hat Morpheus vielleicht irgendwas Interessantes Neues?
Das war das Ende der Messe.
Stimmt, was ist eigentlich mit Trema los?
Windows findet das C-Drive nicht mehr.
Wie jetzt?
Wie?
Aber dann geht ja Windows nicht mehr.
Das heißt, ich sollte besser kein Windows-Update installieren, oder wie ist das?
Sollte ich vielleicht besser kein Windows-Update installieren?
Ist es das, Chatge?
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken.
Okay.
Windows 11 Update causing
blue screen of death and freezes for some users
Windows 11 users are
reporting crashes, freezes, blue screen
of death, failed installs after
but Microsoft still
lists no known issues for
okay
Also sollte ich das...
Okay, ich habe jetzt gelitten. Das ist schon installiert, Leute.
Das ist schon installiert. Pech gehabt.
Earlier today, Microsoft released an emergency hot patch security update to...
Achso.
Moin.
Chainlaw, bist du's?
irgendjemand versucht gerade irgendwelche ASCII Bildchen zu posten
und der Mod sagt, geht nicht
J-Law bist du's
ASCII Art wurde geblockt, ja
Moment, jetzt ist es
erlaubt
Kann ich nicht sagen
Kann ich nicht sagen, hier
check wie kann man vor updates checken wenn es schon pending ist geht das nicht
update history
kann ich das kann ich das nicht wieder an und dann hoffe
man dass man rechner nicht kaputt geht gleich
Was? C-Doppelpunkt Windows Update. Oh, ja.
News.
Okay.
A nasty Windows 11 bug causing the C-Drive to become inaccessible in selected devices.
The Windows Update? Februar Update?
Moment, das Februar Update
hab ich ja schon.
Ich hab keinen Samsung PC.
So ein Samsung-Device cannot find its C-Drives after February update.
Alter.
Vibe-Coded Bullshit, ey.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Microsoft immer so stolz erzählen sollte, dass ihre Entwickler kaum noch Code schreiben, sondern dass alles von AI generiert wird.
Das macht es ja nicht besser.
Netzpläne?
Ja, solange du das nicht mit Visio machen musst.
Visio war früher.
Kennt ihr das noch?
Das war früher ein richtiger Pains Champ.
Visio.
Oh, Gott.
Chat, ich bin geneigt dazu,
jetzt meinen Rechner neu zu starten und zu gucken,
ob es noch funktioniert.
Habe ich noch irgendwas,
was wir gucken können?
Was ist das? Das passt doch zum Thema. Everybody hates the new Microsoft Office.
Okay, jetzt halt mal her.
Was auch immer.
Oh nein!
Wenn ich den Typ schon sehe!
Wenn ich den Typ schon sehe, Alter!
Erinnert ihr euch noch an die
Windows-11-Präsentation, wo sie fast geheult
haben.
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Chat.
Für alle, die es nicht kennen,
Bildungslücke.
Leute, was ich euch jetzt zeige...
WTF, was bin ich hier wieder für
Videos sehend, Alter?
Das ist jetzt kein
Fake oder so. Das war die echte
Windows-11.
Die echte Windows 11 Präsentation.
Das hier.
Der heult fast.
Der weint fast, Alter.
Das ist so schlimm, Alter.
Der Feind, er weint gleich.
Chet, seid ihr auch so emotional immer, wenn ihr an Windows denkt?
Das ist mein Haus.
Das ist ein Scheiß.
Ist das ein Scheiß.
Das ist ein Foto des Hauses, in dem ich geboren bin.
Und es ist das Haus, in dem meine Eltern heute noch leben.
Das war der echte Windows-11-Reveal-Stream.
Alter.
Und so ist doch nicht jetzt nicht Windows auch so für uns.
Was ein Gelaber, Mann.
Our way around.
That's inspiring to me.
And that's what Windows should feel like.
Seid ihr auch so krass inspired von diesem Talk?
Ich bin so heftig inspired, Alter.
It should feel familiar.
It should feel secure.
Ich erlöse euch gleich.
Ich mach gleich aus.
It should feel open.
Connected.
Open.
Especially right now.
Ich will euch nur zeigen, dass das wirklich die Windows 11 Präsentation ist.
Moment, wo geht's los? Ja, hier geht's los.
Also guck, das ist das, wenn ich meine, dass die bei der Windows 11 Präsentation fast geheult haben.
Das ist halt wirklich...
Okay, jetzt wird präsentiert.
Das ist wirklich die Windows 11 Präsentation gewesen.
Also da war mir eigentlich viel lieber...
Best of Steve Ballmer.
Boah, da war der Typ mir ja fast schon lieber.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich mit .NET tun soll, Steve.
Es ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Und es hat eine sehr, sehr klare Antwort.
Entwickler.
Die Schlüssel für .NET, die Schlüssel für Industrietransformation,
die Schlüssel für Erfolg sind Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler, Entwickler.
ganz ehrlich
da fand ich den Kram ja sogar
besser als das was der andere
da getrieben hat das war doch irgendwie lustig
ja
also mir ist es lieber
dass Steve Ballmer rennt über die Bühne ist am ausflippen
als der andere
ich weiß gar nicht wie der heißt, der halt weint, wenn er Windows 11 präsentiert.
Das ist auf jeden Fall unterhaltsamer, oder?
Ich verlaufe was.
So, gucken.
Lass mal anfangen.
Doch angeblich hat Steve Ballmer jemand...
Ähm.
Denn, irgendjemand hat gesagt, er wechselt zu Google.
Und da soll Steve Ballmer angeblich einen Stuhl nach ihm geworfen haben.
Wieso, was hat, das kenne ich nicht, was hat die getrieben?
Hat die auch fast geheult bei Xbox, oder wie?
Der Witz ist ja, ne?
Microsoft hat ja wirklich dieses Announcement gemacht.
Aber danach haben sie ja wieder zurückgerudert und gesagt,
Moment, Moment, Office wird überhaupt nicht in Co-Pilot-App umbenannt.
Aber das konnte man eins zu eins so rauslesen.
Ja, niemand, Leute, jetzt mal ernsthaft, benutzt irgendjemand von euch oder bei euch auf der Arbeit, die ihr kennt.
benutzt, sagt irgendjemand
Microsoft 365 anstelle
von Office. Alle Leute
sagen Office. Und ich kann's by the way
auch absolut nicht verstehen, wie man
Office wirklich umbenennen
konnte.
Echt? Die Leute
sagen Microsoft 365?
WTF, Alter.
Was? Wirklich?
Ich sag Office, es ist jeder
sagt Office.
Ja.
Das war ein Fehler, Leute.
Das war ein Fehler.
Der ist selbst schuld, dass die Leute sich dieses Wort hier ausgedacht haben.
Call it what you're paying us $10 a month for.
And please keep doing that.
As AI has been a roaring success in our software.
Like the Co-Pilot Voice Assistant,
that you get a couple minutes for free,
then you gotta pay for that call, baby.
Talk about a premium phone line.
And it sounds amazing, it feels amazing,
and I get excited, I love it.
Pull it towards you.
Or the AI in Settings,
that's there to help,
unless your question is really simple.
Oh nein, Hilfe, das gibt's ja immer noch, das hab ich ja schon wieder ganz verdrängt.
Recall.
Oh.
Chainlord, Dankeschön, Pock Subscription.
Weil du es bist.
Moment.
Wir brauchen das Geld.
Ah, wir brauchen das Geld, aber wir wollen es.
Der neue Micro-Slop 365.
Wenn ihr dachtet, dass wir vorher schlechte Produkte gemacht haben,
habt ihr noch nichts gesehen.
Abonniert uns!
Aber wir können uns jetzt kein CCC-Talk angucken von 40 Minuten.
Ich krieg langsam Hunger.
Was ist das?
How this SQL command blew up a billion dollar company.
Oh, die Videos guck ich immer gerne.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob wir das nicht schon geguckt haben.
Tabs aufräumen.
Leute, wisst ihr noch, bevor der Neuinstallation, wie viele Tabs ich hatte?
Das ist ja hier der Witz dagegen.
Das ist ja nix, das ist ja noch richtig übersichtlich.
Äh, YouTube?
Robust Security is a must, not an option.
This was part of Heartland Payment Systems' Merchant Bill of Rights,
meant to set the industry standard in credit card processing.
Sitting between the merchant and the card network,
Heartland was responsible for processing 100 million customer transactions per month.
If someone was able to crack...
Ich glaube, das haben wir noch nicht geguckt.
...into their payment system,
prozessor, wo im Fluglicht kreditkarten daten ob er oder ob er nicht alles kreditabssaftig wird,
obwohl er nur pro Monat stehende daten steigt, wäre das ziemlich schlecht, obwohl das nie passiert,
obwohl einige kreditberaterin genießen ihre typische am frlichtag vanilla,
durch hunderten von Webseiten kippen, um eine kreditberaterin kreditabssaftige
zu ihren Angriffen, z.B. die Injektion von Sequel.
Einer lebte in Miami, Florida, während die anderen aus Russland waren.
In 2007 war das doch wild, ja.
Link in the description for a great walkthrough on how it can be carried out.
Quick summary though, the user passes SQL code as input, which the application places into a query.
However, this extra SQL code changes the meaning of the query, causing an unintended output.
And this output is then used elsewhere in the application, causing unintended behavior.
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt, nicht MySQL, es ist Microsoft SQL.
Was sonst?
Übrigens, wisst ihr eigentlich, dass es Microsoft SQL mittlerweile auch für Linux gibt?
Warum auch immer man das machen sollte.
Aber bei mir auf der Arbeit gibt es einen Service, der hat tatsächlich Microsoft SQL Datenbanken unter Linux laufen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da abgeht.
Warum das denn? Das wüsste ich auch gern.
Aber wusstest du, dass man Postgres komplett Oracle-kompatibel laufen lassen kann?
Nee, wusstest du nicht?
Es gibt ja Leute, die sind immer noch der Meinung, sie müssen unbedingt eine Oracle-Datenbank haben.
Doch, Oracle kostet unnormal viel.
Am besten bei Oracle, ich muss ja mal kurz unterbrechen,
was ich bei Oracle immer noch am besten finde,
das hat jetzt nichts mit der Datenbank selbst zu tun,
sind ihre Lizenzdinger.
Ich weiß noch, Oracle hat mal, also gibt es,
Moment mal, ich muss mich mal aufschreiben,
dass ich das nicht vergesse.
Und, ähm, ja, auf der alten Arbeit war das noch.
Da wurde mal sich mit beschäftigt, was man denn mit Oracle Lizenzen so macht.
Und da hatten die auch irgendwelche Berater da für Oracle Lizenzierung und sowas.
Und zumindest kam dann raus, das war mir zum damaligen Zeitpunkt neu,
Chat, da frage ich euch mal, was meint ihr, wie das mit der Lizenzierung ist?
Stellt euch vor, ihr wollt eine Oracle Datenbank betreiben und ihr lasst sie auf einer VM laufen,
auf einer VM mit 8 CPU-Kernen.
Also ihr habt einen Host,
ihr habt einen VMware-Host mit 32
Kernen drin, darauf laufen viele VMs
und darauf erstellt ihr eine Oracle
VM mit 8 Kernen
und wollt die lizenzieren.
Wie viele Kerne müsst ihr
lizenzieren? 8 oder 32?
32!
Korrekt!
Oracle möchte
Oh ne.
Oracle möchte, dass man die darunter liegenden CPUs lizenziert, die die Oracle Datenbank zwar gar nicht benutzen kann, die aber der Host hat, also nicht die, die die VM hat.
Und wisst ihr auch, wie man das damals umgehen konnte? Die wollten damals ihre eigene Virtualisierungssoftware verkaufen. Da gab es irgendeinen Oracle VM Manager oder wie auch immer dieses Ding heißt. Keine Ahnung. Oracle Virtual Manager oder irgendwas. Keine Ahnung, wie dieser Kram heißt.
Ist es das Ding? Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Zumindest haben die so ein eigenes Virtualisierungsding versucht zu verkaufen.
Und wenn du das bei Oracle gekauft hast, dann durftest du deine Datenbanken pro Kern von einer VM lizenzieren.
Also das war einfach ganz hart ihr eigenes Produkt mal wieder reingedrückt.
Dann ging das.
Also dir blieb im Endeffekt gar keine andere Wahl, wie die Oracle-Virtualisierung zu kaufen.
So, und das nächste ist auch ein geiles Ding bei Oracle.
Es gab mal von Oracle was, das nannte sich Oracle Unbreakable Linux.
Jemand von euch die Ehre gehabt, das mal benutzen zu dürfen?
Oracle Unbreakable Linux.
Das ist im Endeffekt
ein Red Hat Fork, glaube ich, gewesen.
Mit einem Oracle Unbreakable
Kernel.
So.
Und
das war quasi ein kostenloser
Red Hat Fork, wenn man so will,
zur damaligen Zeit.
Und ich kann euch
sagen,
das war ein Business Enterprise
Umfeld.
Damals sogar, also haben viele damit geliebäugelt, geliebäugelt, wie nennt man das?
Also sie haben im Endeffekt, haben überlegt das zu benutzen als kostenlose Red Hat Alternative.
So, das Problem bei Oracle ist jetzt nur, stellt euch vor, ihr betreibt 400 Linux Kisten mit Oracle Unbreakable Linux.
Ihr macht das, weil das eine kostenlose Red Hat Alternative ist.
So, dann habt ihr eine Oracle Datenbank und wollt euch Support dafür kaufen.
Jetzt habt ihr ein Problem.
Ihr denkt jetzt natürlich, ihr kauft euch einfach Support für die Datenbank und gut ist.
Nicht so bei Oracle.
Oracle hat in ihren Lizenzbedingungen, zumindest meines Wissens nach, damals war das so,
eine Bedingung drin stehen, dass wenn ihr auch nur ein Oracle-Produkt lizenziert und Support kauft,
müssen alle anderen Oracle-Produkte, die ihr auch noch habt, mindestens den gleichen Support-Level oder Lizenz-Level haben.
Das heißt, ihr müsstet dann auf einmal alle 400 Unbreakable Linux auch mindestens mit der Support-Stufe lizenzieren,
wie ihr eure Datenbank lizenziert habt.
Also aus, ich geb mal ein paar tausend Euro für Datenbankkosten aus, wären dann auf einmal, ich geb mal ein paar Millionen aus geworden.
Also Oracle ist, was Lizenzierung anbelangt, ganz schlimm.
Am besten, er macht so einen großen Bogen wie irgendwie möglich um Oracle.
Ja, kein Wunder, dass der Oracle-Typ so reich ist. Von nix kommt nix, ja.
Welche Smart Home-Sachen würdest du jedem Haushalt empfehlen?
Das, was dir eigentlich am meisten Arbeit abnimmt.
Also viele fangen ja mit Lampen und Beleuchtung an.
Das finde ich jetzt persönlich gar nicht mal so geil als erstes.
Also smarte Steckdosen sind relativ universell.
Die kann man für ganz viel, ganz viel verwenden.
Ja, da kann angefangen von, du kannst gucken, ob die Waschmaschine schon fertig ist.
Wenn du eine smarte Steckdose hast, wo du guckst, wie viel Verbrauch da gerade drüber läuft.
Also Steckdosen sind auf jeden Fall eine sehr sinnvolle Geschichte.
wenn du klimaanlagen hast generell heizung und klimaanlagen sind auch nice aber du musst dir
erst mal überlegen was dich was was sich persönlich nervt und die am meisten bringen würde ja also
fenstersensoren finde ich jetzt auch sinnvoll dass du beispielsweise eine push notification
kriegen kannst aufs handy wenn du vergessen hast beispielsweise im ersten stock das badfenster zu
zuzumachen und willst gerade das Haus verlassen und sowas.
Es gibt sehr viele Sachen.
Ist aber ziemlich individuell.
Kann man so
pauschal so das sagen.
Wobei pauschal finde ich, kann man sagen,
jetzt anzufangen mit Lichtern
ist meistens gar nicht so sinnvoll.
Ich weiß, da fangen viele damit an, weil das sowas
offensichtliches ist, aber
ich bin der Meinung, die meisten Leute machen es falsch
und es ist dann gar nicht so geil
wie gedacht. Also mit falsch
meine ich, die Leute tauschen dann ihre
Lichter durch irgendwelche
RGB Lampen aus, da gibt es ja schon mehrere Probleme dabei. Das erste ist, RGB Lampen,
wir sind im meisten, Großteil der Fälle eigentlich gar nicht erforderlich. Es gibt ja verschiedene
smarte Lichter. Das einfachste ist eine Lampe, die man beispielsweise über ZigBee oder über
WLAN ein- und ausschalten kann. Das nächste ist eine Lampe, die man ein- und ausschalten
kann und dimmen kann.
Das nächste ist eine Lampe,
die man ein- und ausschalten kann, dimmen kann
und die Farbtemperatur
ändern kann. Und erst danach
kommt eine richtige RGB-Lampe.
Und dementsprechend ist das preislich auch
gestaffelt und bei den
allermeisten Anwendungsgebieten,
wenn man einfach nur
Licht haben möchte, braucht es
keine RGB-Lampe.
Spätestens eine Lampe
mit Farbtemperatur reicht
komplett.
In den ganz, also in den wenigsten Fällen braucht man eine wirklich echte RGB-Lampe.
Und dann als RGB, wenn man sich RGB-Sachen kauft, also Lichterketten und sowas,
dann sollte man auch drauf gucken, dass man ordentliche Lichterketten kauft.
Also was mit RGB plus weiße LED.
Ja.
Und das nächste, was viele meiner Meinung nach bei Lichtern auch falsch machen, ist,
Die machen sich dann eine RGB-Lampe rein und denken dann, jawohl, das ist es. Das Problem ist nur, sobald du den Lichtschalter drückst, ist deine super smarte RGB-Lampe überhaupt nicht mehr smart, weil der Strom ab ist, Strom aus ist.
Das heißt, dann muss man sich auch Gedanken drüber machen
Okay, wie kann ich das dann anbinden
Und ist es vielleicht nicht besser
Die ganz normale Lampe
Drinnen zu lassen
Und vielleicht den Schalter smart zu machen
Also dass man sowohl über Smart Home ein- und ausschalten kann
Als auch über den Schalter
Also da gibt es viele Sachen
Also ich behaupte einfach, die meisten Leute
wenn die mit rgb anfangen wird es ein ziemlicher reinfall
ja kirche wohnzimmer partner weiß so würde ich wahrscheinlich auch machen ja
also gerade im schlafzimmer ich habe im schlafzimmer übrigens gar kein rgb da
kann ich verstehen so von der stimmung her vom licht her im wohnzimmer kann ich
auch bei manchen verstehen aber bei den meisten reicht das wirklich wenn man eine
Lampe hat, die einfach nur die
Farbtemperatur ändern kann.
Ja, wenn du da nicht dran willst, dann würde ich sagen,
kann ich auch
nur befürworte, da nicht dran rumzubasteln,
wenn man keine Ahnung hat.
Dann lass es halt mit RGB
am Anfang und mach was anderes.
So, jetzt bin ich komplett sidetracked worden.
Wir wollten uns doch eigentlich hier irgendwas angucken.
Hier, SQL.
Oh Leute, ich hab so krass Hunger.
Ich muss noch kurz mein Handy holen.
Warte mal.
Gerade kurz was checken.
Äh, hallo? Andy, please?
Alles klar. So, weiter, gucken wir mal hier, was denn jetzt eigentlich SQL-mäßig passiert ist.
Ich muss mal kurz zurück.
Link-Libraries, which are files that contain
code, usually C++,
which when executed by process...
Chat, wer von euch High-IQ-Leuten
weiß, was das Gegenstück von einer DLL
unter Linux ist?
Also welche
Endung?
Ja, richtig, Alfred.
Excellent.
Punkt SO.
Shed ist einfach way too schlau.
Okay, da hast du ja schon mal die Arschkarte, sobald das funktioniert.
Da hast du, wenn du auf Shed kannst, alles mitmachen.
your sequel client well use cases generally involve wiping the entire server i mean for
database admins to strategically punkt a punkt a files sind doch glaube ich statisch gelingt
oder war das nicht so punkt a ist statisch so archive mäßig und punkt s o ist dynamic
Interact with the server's file system in various ways, such as listing, copying or renaming files.
You could also combine this with the scheduled job feature to perform automated tasks,
like generating a daily summary of a table as an output file.
But like Stack Overflow Guy and the FBI recommends, probably don't use it.
Move this complex logic to the application layer if possible.
Ja, ist doch ganz einfach. Einfach den Datenbank-Server als Admin laufen lassen. Easy.
Dann gibt's auch keine rechten Probleme mehr.
Okay, zwei Sachen.
Einfach unter Linux
jedes Verzeichnis 777
und die Sachen
als root laufen lassen. Dann ist
überhaupt kein Problem mehr. Dann hast du
keinerlei Permission-Probleme.
Which determines whether or not they are able
to run XP Command Shell in the
first place. Secondly, the Windows
user, which started the SQL Server
process, will have a certain level of operating
system privilege.
Da hast du wieder Windows.
Bisschen schon, ja.
...what XP Command Shell is able to do.
But allegedly this random web portal was connected to SQL Server with sysadmin credentials.
Na toll!
The process was also started by a fairly privileged user.
Therefore the attackers were able to execute Command Shell and download what the FBI calls their hacker tools.
Most importantly this includes setting up a backdoor, so they can get in and out even if the front door gets patched.
Das ist alles in der Firma's Corporate Network.
Per Payment Card Industry Data Security Standards,
muss Heartland's Payment Processing System,
das Kundenkreditkartentaktionen handelt,
in einer separaten Netzwerke bleiben.
Glücklicherweise haben die Hackers all die Zeit in der Welt,
um sich umzuschauen, sich mit dem Stack zu kennen
und die Onboarding-Dokumentation zu lesen.
Tja.
Bis jetzt hat Heartland eine Verbrechung der Corporate Network bemerkt.
Chat, was haltet ihr davon?
Wollen wir uns demnächst mal Windows Server 2025 angucken zusammen?
Ich kann euch aber jetzt schon gleich sagen,
das wird kein wahrscheinlich sonderlich wohlwollender Stream.
Wir brauchen aber noch eine Aufgabe dafür.
Einfach nur angucken ist doof.
Wir brauchen eine Aufgabe, sowas wie eine .NET-Web-Anwendung hosten oder sowas.
Und dann durchdrehen unter Windows.
Nee, nee, nee, AD mach ich bestimmt nicht. Hör mal bloß auf.
Also ganz so massen schissig bin ich ja noch nicht veranlagt.
Und das Kommando habe ich ja schon wieder
voll vergessen. Da hatten wir mal
einen im Chat, der
rumgeschwurbelt hat in der Richtung.
Video fertig gucken.
Was macht eigentlich...
Oh, wie hießen die?
Ah, wie, da gab's ja auch so eine Security...
Nee, nicht die hier.
So eine Security-Firma, die...
Strike, CrowdStrike.
CrowdStrike.
Was macht Rollstrike eigentlich?
Ist das eigentlich genauso eingetroffen, wie ich gesagt habe,
dass das in ein paar Monaten keine Sau mehr interessiert
und einfach weiter benutzt wird?
Ja, anscheinend.
Anscheinend ist es genauso.
Hast du noch Aktien?
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe noch welche.
Also ich habe ja mal Just for Fun eine oder so gekauft.
Vielen Dank.
System for a bit over four months at this point.
Sometime in May, the hackers were able to make the jump to the payment processing network.
How did they do that?
Heartland manages objects in their networks such as users, servers, network devices with
Microsoft Active Directory.
Active Directory groups these objects into organizational units.
These organizational units are then grouped into domains.
These domains are grouped into trees and these trees are grouped into four sets, at least
According to this illustration I found online.
The forests sind es eigentlich, oder?
Anyways, just like real life, this is a hierarchical organization
where most users only have access to the stuff at their low levels.
But there are inevitably going to be a few privileged users
of the highest level that can access pretty much everything.
Let's say the hackers landed around here.
This would be the user which launched SQL Server.
You can probably see where this is going.
In order to verify the identity of users,
Heartland hat ein Authentication-Protokoll genannt, das heißt NTLM, oder NT Land Manager.
Das bietet ein einziges Sign-on, das einen Kunden ermöglicht,
zu verbinden mit verschiedenen Services mit dem gleichen Passwort.
Wie du zu YouTube, LinkedIn und McDonalds mit deinem Google-Account loggen kannst,
können die Heartlander mit ihren Windows-Kredenzialen eine ermittelte aktive Ressource verbinden.
Es gibt viele Authentication-Protokolle, und NTLM ist nur ein Fisch im Pond.
Aber der Witz ist, dass sie alle designt sind, um den Netzwerk Plaintext-Kredenzialen zu verhindern.
Im Grunde genommen ist der Raum zwischen dem Klienten und dem Server, wo die Pakete gesendet werden,
verzeichnet als der Hell auf der Erde.
Und wenn irgendein ungeencryptes Passwort seinen Weg da reinführt,
wird ein Goblin aus dem Wald kommen, das Passwort nehmen und dich und deine Familie hacken.
von NTLM ein komplett anderer ist als von Linux und deswegen braucht Samba eine eigene User-Datenbank,
wo es den Windows-Hashing-Algorithmus für Passwörter verwendet. Lag das nicht auch an NTLM?
Ich bilde mir einer wahr was.
The protocol is set up by giving the server all of the users hashed passwords.
When a user wants to prove they are who they say they are,
the server challenges the user to a duel and sends the user a random number.
The user must perform the agreed upon math operation using this number and their password hash
and send it back to the server, who performs the same function using its known hash.
If they match, the user is authenticated.
If they don't match, the user is...
Kann man das wenigstens deaktivieren?
Es ist aber auch möglich, dass Passwörter einfach nur gezwungen wurden,
nachdem der extrem lange Zeit, zwischen denen sie sich bewegen,
in der Berufsschule war.
Einerseits war es durch eine Art von Methoden,
dass die Aktivitäts-Direktoren-User verurteilt wurden.
Privilegiert wurde eskaliert, die Sicherheit wurde verurteilt.
Mit ihrer neu gefundenen, hochprivilegierten Status
konnten sie wahrscheinlich ein unbekanntes Niveau von Hosts
durchlaufen, um sie zu ihrer Destination zu erreichen.
Einmal in der Payment-Netzwerk
haben sie ihre Paket-Schnippen-Software gebootet
und begannen, In-Flight-Package zu fangen, die über das Netz flogen.
Sie entdeckten, dass die Package ungeencrypte Karten,
Expirationsdaten und die Magnetik-Strippe-Informationen enthaltenen.
Noch fünf Monate später notifizierte Visa Heartland,
dass sich über bestimmte Kartenhäuser-Aktivitäten verabschieden.
Heartland engagierte Forensische Auditorien, um zu investigieren,
und es würde nicht bis Monate später sein, dass die Packageneinigung entdeckt würde.
Na gut, ehrlich gesagt ist das doch nicht so spannend.
Ich dachte, da gibt es jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr Richtung SQL-Injection und sowas.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Chat, ich habe so heftig Hunger.
Was habe ich denn heute Morgen nochmal gesagt?
Lass mich nochmal dran erinnern.
Ich habe gesagt, heute Mittag können wir vielleicht was ausprobieren noch auf dem Nass.
Ach so, wie schnell.
Wie schnell Samba-Stelz im LXC-Container ist, können wir ausprobieren.
Ich habe noch mal eine andere Frage, Chatge.
Was gibt es?
Es gibt Reis.
Reis mit...
Kurz überlegen.
Rainlake.
Garnelen.
Richtig, der Chat weiß besser
als ich, was es
mir zu essen gibt.
Reis mit Garnelen. Richtig.
Chat ist einfach zu schlau.
Nee, es gibt keine Bolognese oder Lachs.
Okay, dann werden wir gleich das erste Chain-Lore.
Das finde ich ja geil.
Hat er aus meinem Video.
Ja, wartet mal.
Komm, das nehme ich.
Das nehme ich.
Es müsste eigentlich hinzugefügt worden sein.
Ging das jetzt?
Ne, ne, ne.
Das hat sie noch nicht gecheckt.
Verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Geht? Echt? Bei mir noch nicht.
Einfach zu.
Hat noch nicht schnell genug gesynct.
hier hören wir mal hier aus.
Ah, ich hab immer noch nicht das,
dass ich, dass ich
Anwendungen zumachen kann.
Nee.
Das hat's noch nicht gecheckt.
Aber bei euch geht's, oder was?
Wo liegt?
Wo liegt 2? Hä?
Ja, ich benutze das auch.
Also
Keine Ahnung
Es ist problem
Na gut, dann nicht
Geht nicht, dann brauchst du noch ein bisschen
Bis das funktioniert
Oder Chainlaw musste das vielleicht noch irgendwie
Wobei man sieht ja sogar, dass ich das hinzugefügt hab
Warte mal, ich mach das jetzt mal anders.
Ich mach das jetzt nochmal weg.
Aus dem Channel.
Jetzt sag ich nochmal Add to Channel.
Confirm Change.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Whatever.
Dann geht's nächsten Stream erst.
Unlisted
Emotes.
Ne.
Die will ich nicht einschalten.
Muss der Chainlord, muss das
dann freigeben oder so. Keine Ahnung.
So. Was wollte ich jetzt hier nochmal auf meiner
linux kiste irgendwas wollte ich euch auch gerade noch zeigen wird verpeilt wieder
keine ahnung
kogos wieder updates gibt
jawohl chat wir haben jetzt schon eine stunde keine updates mehr gemacht endlich neue updates
ich bin überhaupt nicht so blieb genug was sind deine top sachen zu hausen also auf box ich werde
letztendlich alles drauf laufen lassen was ich jetzt auch auf der anderen kiste laufen meine
anwalt kiste laufen lassen habe das dann mein homo system drauf laufen das sage ich die hauptsache
homo system drauf laufen dann das für meine kameras wo ich bei web rtc die die überwachung
Kameras angucken kann.
Äh, in Git.
Die Frage
ist, Leute,
was würdet ihr nehmen?
Würdet ihr
Gitti oder Gitea nehmen oder
Forgio mittlerweile?
Ich kann keinen wirklichen
Vorteil von dem einen gegenüber dem
anderen sehen.
Also Forgio ist ja das, wo Codeberg
auch drauf läuft.
Nee, GitLab würde ich nicht
nehmen, weil
GitLab ist
sehr, sehr
bloated zu hosten.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die
Closed Source sind.
FHGO ist ja ein
GTA 4 Fork.
Also GitLab braucht ziemlich
viel Ressourcen.
Ich habe hier auf meinem...
Oh, ich habe die Kiste gar nicht an. Kann ich auch nicht
drauf. Also mein NAS hat glaube ich
32 GB RAM. Davon sind
2 GB für die Grafikkarte reserviert.
Für KI-Stelz.
Ja.
Dann probiere ich es vielleicht auch mal mit
4GEO.
4GEO, 4GEO, wie auch immer
man es genau spricht.
Die Repos umziehen dürfte ja wahrscheinlich
relativ einfach sein. Einfach ins
neue Repo pushen und gut ist.
kann man gibt es eine gibt es eine möglichkeit geht er also quasi ford upgrade zu machen von
gta so dass man sein altes zeug weiter verwenden kann ich habe noch eine uralte
gt gt gta versionen von mir lokal weil die halt einfach geht
einmal gucken und ausprobieren
lenz es habe ich hier laufen war das nicht irgendeine kubernetes ach nee ach das ist
auch so lokales hardtop ding wo ich auch nicht weiß was man damit machen soll oder sinn davon
ist ich bleibe dabei hat ob es nach wie vor beste nicht beethoven ich kläre es
nicht sonst was hat ob beste warum ist kleinste sky chat ich werde das super
unübersichtlich
Glances-W, da hast du das Webinterface.
Ja, okay, aber warum?
H-Top ist beste.
Beste.
H-Top.
Und nachdem H-Top mittlerweile auch IO, Bandbreiten-Krams-Überwachung hat,
ist das für mich immer noch das Beste.
Also, wenn ich einen Server finde, wo
H-Top nicht installiert ist, ist das erste, was ich mache,
gleich nachinstallieren.
Nee, B-Top mag ich nicht.
Wir hatten es ja mal drauf. B-Top ist mir auch
zu überladen. Das einzig
coole bei B-Top ist,
dass du noch Netzwerktraffic dabei hast.
Also, ja,
B-Top ist ja B-Top,
quasi.
Oder der Vorgänger davon,
oder irgendwie sowas.
Also, wenn H-Top
jetzt noch Network Traffic hätte,
dann wäre es perfekt.
Gucken wir mal. H-Top, gibt es das auf GitHub?
H-Top, Interactive Browser Viewer.
Gibt es da vielleicht
ein Feature Request für Netzwerk Traffic?
Äh.
Oh.
Alter, Shithub.
Easy.
Disk Network Combined Meter.
Aha.
Moment.
H-Top hat schon Network?
Bin ich einfach nur zu dumm?
Can H-Top show Network usage?
Nee, kann's nicht, oder?
Die Discon Networks Meters können einfach in eine...
Ja.
Wie jetzt?
Gab's das denn schon mal?
Combined Meter.
I like to see Combined Meter for Discon Network Activities Simulator.
Also das scheint ja doch irgendwie sowas zu haben.
Aber es ist, aber hier hast du nur Discpile.
Bin ich jetzt, bin ich jetzt zu dumm oder was dafür?
Ne, das war vielleicht mal, das war vielleicht mal geplant oder so.
H-Top-Counting-Network?
Ja doch.
Jetzt habe ich F2 gedrückt.
F2 hat komische Dinger gemacht.
Chat.
F2 switcht den Desktop.
Das ist schlecht.
Meters.
Nee, das kann nur.
Clock? Date?
Seht ihr irgendwas von Network?
Network?
Moment, das kann Network?
Oh, geil.
Äh, und was habe ich jetzt? Wo ist es jetzt?
Column 2.
Ach, hier!
Ah, so. Okay.
Ah, das kann nur Insgesamtnetwork anzeigen.
Ich dachte, das kann sowas wie IOPRO-Prozess anzeigen.
Nee, das kann's nicht.
Okay, weil das wäre halt richtig nice gewesen, wenn es hier noch einen Tab für Network Traffic gäbe, so wie Disk.io.
Ja, so dieses insgesamt, ja, das ist ganz nice, aber das brauchen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Ich dachte, das kann es vielleicht auch pro Prozess anzeigen.
Ja, ich weiß, Glanzen und Btop kann es auch, aber ich mag das UI von Htop einfach.
Ich finde es so clean und übersichtlich und beste einfach.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab mich sehr an H-Top gewöhnt.
Ich weiß, Glanzes kann das und B-Top kann das auch.
Ich wüsste aber, ich wüsste beispielsweise in Glanzes schon mal gar nicht,
wie ich überhaupt umschalte zu Netzwerktraffic.
Hier oben sehe ich den Gesamtnetzwerktraffic.
Netzwerktraffic pro Prozess.
Keine Ahnung wie.
Brauchen wir auch nicht.
ist es scheint zumindest relativ kühl zu bleiben.
Wisst ihr, was ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert habe?
Ich habe noch gar nicht ausprobiert,
wie heiß dieser Mini-PC wird,
wenn ich mal volle Pulle CPU-Last mache.
Das probieren wir mal kurz aus.
Das hier ist die CPU-Temperatur.
Warum das so einen dummen Namen hat, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich sage euch, das hier ist die CPU-Temperatur.
Machen wir mal.
Guck mal hier.
100% CPU-Last.
Bam.
Bam, bababam.
Temperatur geht direkt hoch.
Wir können auch einfach hier sagen Sensors.
Gap.
Vielleicht noch besser.
Okay.
Mal gucken, was der Lüfter macht.
Es ist immer noch ziemlich leise, das Ding.
Trotz voller Pulle CPU.
Ich glaube, der dreht erst richtig hoch, wenn es eine Weile heiß war.
Ah, jetzt.
Okay, okay, jetzt dreht der Lüfter ordentlich rauf gerade.
Jaja, jetzt pustet er ordentlich.
Was ist denn bei Ryzen-CPUs so die...
Das, was man nicht überschreiten sollte.
90 Grad, 95 Grad.
Bei Intel ist es glaube ich 105 oder so, wo es critical, wo es sich runter taktet.
Aber es bleibt relativ stable auf 78 Grad unter Volllast.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, 79, 78 Grad, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich meine, wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
das Ding hat gerade 16,
nein, 16 stimmt nicht, 8 Kerne,
16 Threads komplett ausgelastet.
Da kannst du nichts sagen, oder?
Okay, machen wir mal wieder aus.
Ich will es jetzt ja nicht unnötig aufheizen,
das Ding.
Okay, Chat, was haltet ihr davon?
Ich gehe jetzt was essen und nachher, sagen wir mal irgendwie so 14 Uhr oder so rum,
machen wir dann Samba-Stells auf dem Nass und gucken mal,
ob wir das im LXC-Container schneller hinkriegen als, oder 14.30, mal gucken,
ob wir es im LXT-Container schneller hinkriegen
als in der VM.
Ja?
Oder so.
Du kalibrierst deinen CRT.
Warum hast du einen CRT?
Für irgendwelche Retro-Geschichten
oder was?
Das würde mich jetzt noch interessieren.
War 50 Euro steht Nokia drauf mit Sony-Röhre.
Ja, aber warum?
Also, einfach haben. Einfach so, ja.
Okay, verstehe.
Verstehe, Chat.
Alles klar?
Dann würde ich sagen,
sehen wir uns später.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.